et leur maintenance et leur fait parfois
difficiles mais là vous êtes ponctuelles
et donc ça tient certainement à
l'intérêt des sujets qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui la différenciation tous
égaux plus différent on va essayer de
répondre à la question avec deux tables
rondes différenciation et droit
d'exception ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et puis préparer là demain ce qui
pourrait se passer comment organiser
différenciation et les républiques et
centraliser les fameux 3d
décentralisation déconcentration
différenciation mais avant d'entendre
nos experts avant de rentrer dans les
débats
je vous propose d'écouter le message du
président du sénat gérard larcher qui
malheureusement ne pourrait pas être
avec nous cet après midi mais qui a tenu
à s'exprimer demande sur ce sujet à
travers les images
madame la ministre cherche un gros
monsieur le président du groupe de
l'union centriste hervé marseille
chers collègues sénateurs chers
collègues députés chers collègues élus
mesdames et messieurs je regrette de ne
pas être parmi vous cet appel
j'aurais souhaité être présente pas pour
ce colloque organisé par le groupe de
l'union centriste
à l'initiative de son président hervé
manse à ce sujet un sujet important la
différence chez chantiers j'ai ce côté
vous avez c est ce bref message que le
crash très dandy l'actualité législative
particulièrement dense pour nos
territoires
le sénat va examiner d'ici quelques
jours le projet de loi engagement et
proximité qui traite notamment de la
place et des compétences de la commune
au sein de l'intercommunalité ainsi que
les conditions d'exercice des mandats
lucide je ne doute pas que notre
assemblée sera des propositions de tabac
pour approfondir les assouplissements en
matière les compétences le périmètre à
dire comme une autre avec un souci de
simplification de clarté et pour
renforcer le thon rouge et la finance
pour 2020 qui est présenté cette semaine
à cause des mini comportera une réforme
de la fiscalité locale
il sera pas sans conséquence sur
l'autonomie financière et fiscale de nos
collectivités
ce soit les communes l'enveloppement or
il est un principe que sans maîtrise
bien sûr les libertés locales ne peuvent
c'est à ce moment c'est ce qui a conduit
le groupe de travail du sénat qui ont la
révision constitutionnelle a proposé
dans son rapport de janvier de l'église
ou de mieux garantir la compensation
financière transfert des créations
on aura forcé l'article 72 de la
constitution sur les garanties
d'autonomie financière et fiscale de nos
collégiens
enfin le parlement sera je le ferai a
bien discuté le printemps prochain d'un
texte portant une nouvelle étape dès sa
promulgation la nouvelle le lac et
sociétal qui a secoué le pays l'hiver
dernier a souligné le besoin de revenir
au réel de plérin et les cigognes
certains territoires et des habitants
ont le sentiment d'être bien vu car de
se voir imposer des décisions arrêtées
façon lointaine par d'autres et souvent
conçus dans une société de plus en plus
diverses mais aussi fragile par
l'intensité mutation le pouvoir est plus
s'organiser
il s'agit en fait d'une manière
centralisée et ne pas qu'il faille entré
dans une nouvelle logique de redonner à
notre pays d'accord c'est la cohésion
lui manque de vent puiser dans l'artois
nutella en redonnant le cas la liberté
de concevoir d'adapter et d'entretien
vraiment vraiment plaisant aussi la
république à une pulsion assemblée
c'est la raison de nombreuses voix
s'élèvent pour porter l'idée d'un réseau
décentralisés les aussi de faire avancer
la différenciation petit koné colloque
ils vont réaliser
le résumé la complexité
comment concevoir une organisation
territoriale corps repartir et répartir
dans une logique ils y arrêtaient des
compétences entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales guitare d'en
être les collectivités elles-mêmes
comment adapter des politiques
d'efficacité
comment simplifier le maquis juridique
et administratif et redonner le seul
unités aux murs et tout cela sans
enterrer le principe d'unité pratiques
auxquelles nous sommes attachés dans la
première partie du colloque
vous aurez à discuter a essayé de faire
le bilan les éléments existent en
matière de différenciation
je pense pas dans le droit à
l'expérimentation introduit en 2003 dans
notre constitution est aussi aux
avancées récentes comme la création d'un
ministre de la collectivité européenne à
grasse où la signature d'un pacte
accessibilité pour la bretagne entre la
région et l'état
c'est un exemple peuvent constituer un
danger ou bien vite il a essayé de
concevoir droit le droit la
différenciation dans un quart de seconde
partie sera interdit de rêver leur sonar
vous conduire à terme regard prospectif
et vous intervenez sur l'avenir de la
monarchie peut être contribué à cette
nouvelle génération que j'ai voté il ya
quelques années une nouvelle génération
centralisation qui vivent sur le respect
à conserver
il a eu la prescience c'est essentiel
une nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation qui met un terme aux
relations parfois suspicieuse entre
l'état et les collectivités qu'elle
était une nouvelle génération
centralisation qui va enfin une nouvelle
génération de la rue jean de la
décentralisation
il remporte principe de subsidiarité
dans une logique de proximité et ils
revenaient encore qui puisse garantir
l'autonomie financière
dès que je voudrais saluer tous les
intervenants est venu professeurs
chercheurs ont répondu à l'invitation du
président marcel leur expérience riche
et diverse apportera une forte lumière
utiles sur cette question complexe mais
à mes yeux essentielles pour l'avenir
vous souhaitez les échanges cet après
midi studieux et fructueuse relégué à
tous et maintenant je vais appeler jean
marc inizan sénateur de la moselle
il va être bien
par ces messieurs le moral municipal qui
s'achève aura été à plusieurs titres à
nouveau
jamais depuis tant d'années les communes
avaient connu de tel chambardement
d'octane modifications si peu de temps
avez-vous la réforme territoriale et ses
conséquences sur à de nombreuses
intercommunalités et nouveau transfert
des compétences
quand aimé cette même raison la baisse
parfois sévères des dotations de l'état
et ses répercussions sur les budgets
locaux aient pu que les ça manque cash
suppression partielle ou totale pas
progressif de la taxe d'habitation
on l'appelle pour laquelle nous n'avons
pas encore tous les éléments d'un pack
notamment sur ses anciennes directions
de certaines scènes sont toutes ces
épisodes douloureux qui ont un goût amer
chez de nombreux élus locaux ont aussi
contribué à leur découragement
au point qu'on estime aujourd'hui qu'un
maire suppléant ne se
présentera pas dans moins de six noms
d'oncles soit également les locaux qui
demandent une pause dans les réformes
qu'elle concerne les nouveaux transferts
de compétences imposée par la loi depuis
paris où les nouveaux mouvements
toujours plus grand l'alcoolémie
sionisme gigantisme
si la résignation et massive et n'est
cependant pas général
la bonne nouvelle c'est que l'ambition
des maires pour leur commune les deux
murs est atteinte
les verts ont et gardent la foi parent
l'enfant des farouches et ouvert leurs
portes et à mener à bien les projets
pour lesquels ils se sont engagés et
dans ce contexte me semble qu'une
réforme qui n'impose rien à personne
oubliez le champ des possibles à ceux
qui le souhaitent qu'ils tiendraient
compte des spécificités de chaque
collectivité pour donner davantage de
souffle à la chaleur qui permettrait de
traiter de manière différente des
situations différentes
pour une plus grande égalité entre les
territoires
pour peu que l'on estime pertinente la
pensée de larry scott qui considérait
que les traités de manière égale
ce qui est vendable et 2
différents il n'y a pas ce qu'elle
simple une réponse qui renouerait avec
l'idée de tout reste tout pas local
marco hassine rupture d'avec la quasi
unanimité des décisions prises jusqu'ici
uniformité généralisée j'étais quelque
sorte une négation des systèmes à m même
costume
happy world sont différents sens
différent cqb des formes géant ça ne
comporterait pas de mesures incitatives
pour que les âges les je ne confonds pas
le budget une telle réforme de son pote
il serait dommage et à séduire tout
simplement parce qu'elle ne comporte
aucune contrainte aucune brutalité mais
au contraire à les inscrire dans un
rapport de confiance avec les élus
locaux et la connaissance dix ans ils
sont confrontés à cette réforme est
annoncée depuis quelques temps déjà
c'est la différenciation territoriales
qui fait l'actualité depuis richard -
c'est une autre manière d'appréhender
d'action publique locale en tout cas
elle semble intéresser nos concitoyens à
en juger par le scandale des résultats
du sondage mené par clifford débute ce
mois de septembre pour le compte du
groupe des sénateurs centristes sondage
duquel je relèverai 2 qe2 les questions
la première
c'était seriez vous favorable à ce que
la répartition des compétences à 10 puis
à collectivités locales puissent varier
d'un territoire à l'autre ça comme ça
pour cent des personnes sondées
la seconde question les résultats il est
plutôt était la suivante dès lors que le
parlement on aurait également accepté le
principe solide favorable ou pas
favorable à ce que les collectivités
locales puissent adopter des normes
particulières ou introduire des
dérogations à une loi votée à l'échelle
nationale
61% des sondés ont répondu qu'ils y
étaient favorables mais force est de
reconnaître le contenu l'a tellement ses
contours
son objectif c'est vingt six apportées
ne sont pas perçus de la même manière
par tous d'où l'intérêt du colloque
quillan permettent de progresser dans la
poche de ce qu'il recouvre réellement
concrètement et qui doit aussi permettre
à nous c'est un tueur sans prise de nous
préciser notre manière de voir enfin la
mise en oeuvre du sevrage durée
nécessite un certain nombre d'évolutions
que je rencontre de cet après midi là
permettre d'aborder dans la série
[Applaudissements]
nous allons rentrer dans la première
partie du colloque intitulé
différenciation et droit détection
on va commencer par un état de droit qui
existe déjà ce qui est possible et
d'exercice a été confiée à gerland
chaque année pour le sort public à lire
par ailleurs
merci messieurs les financiers d'ouvrir
les débats de solutions parce qu'elle
est porteuse d'espoir monseigneur
d'interrogation elle permet
effectivement
et pourtant dans cette assemblée tout
mon encontre
qu'est ce qu'on a fait beaucoup par
exemple lorsqu'on a distingué deux
flûtes or entre les communes ont besoin
du temps haletante
c'est une seule et celle de monde on a
tenu compte d'une différence de
situation qui est dans les petites
communes et concertées d'organiser de
représentation politique qu'est ce qu'on
a fait d'autres lorsque pour
l'intercommunalité
lorsque l'intérieur des
intercommunalités on a proposé des
listes de compétences parmi lesquels
choisir en fonction du projet de
l'histoire de la technicité des prises
qu'est ce qu'on a fait l'objet quand on
a permis selon lyon et marseille qui
sont pas pas statut particulier contre
un peuple d'être organisé un peu
différente de la taille de ces villes
sachant que la différence hier quand il
s'agit de l'organisation de connecter
des garçons pour effectivement un
collectif
les murs sont blancs qu'est ce qu'on a
fait notre canton à adopter la loi du 9
janvier 1985 relative par nolan a exposé
d'un titre tous intitulée du droit en
prise en compte des différences déjà en
titre et l'article 8 disposent les
dispositions de portée générale sont
adaptées en tant que de besoin à la
spécificité
s'il faut tenir compte des différences
massif par macif aucun raconte des
différences massif pharmacie pour la
différenciation et du tourisme en effet
différencier c'est traiter différents
déplacements
il conseille toujours reconnu que le
principe d'égalité empêche ou pas de
traiter différemment des situations dit
lorsque ces différences peuvent être
mises en évidence par les critères parce
que même pour les vendre l'objectif par
exemple pour la tarification
il ya plus important lorsque les
différenciations entre usagers entre
individus pour la tarification des
services publics on peut avoir une
différence partir d'un militaire qui
peut être par exemple le meilleur
particulier avec la commune
ce n'est pas déroger au principe
d'égalité
c'est là qu'est ce qui est des rougeurs
principe d'égalité souvent les choses
pendant un conseil constitutionnel c'est
l'intérêt général en lien avec le jazz -
permet effectivement de traiter
différemment n'y rien comprendre à
l'exemple twitter lassé par ce but et ne
met pas l'impératif qui nécessitent
contrex différemment cette situation
même si sa demande est logé à l'égalité
mais sinon traiter différentes
situations différentes
c'est pas du tout les jours qu'un cd
gagner beaucoup plus de 5
ces latitudes le conseil constitutionnel
dans une décision 1995 mme lohan
orientations d'aménagement et de
développement du thème 3 avec à
connaître d'une situation il y avait une
disposition dans un grade et une
application
ensuite au niveau local par de profonds
de cannes et là nous explique que le
législateur avec la passe
fonctions locales prévoyant la passation
de conventions locales destinées à tenir
compte des spécificités des situations
territoriales a mis en place une
procédure de méconnaître le principe
d'égalité constitue un moyen d'en
assurer la mise en 1995 le conseil
constitutionnel la différenciation c'est
un point rassurez vous voyez ce n'est
pas du tout révolutionnaire alors
comment faire dans ces conditions ça se
précise pour certains ppp différemment
des situations différentes c'est pour
regarder principe d'égalité comme
respecter
nous on n'a pas voulu faire d'abord dans
son coeur de la 5008 et d'état au 6 mars
on avait mis en boîte une communauté
mais en tout cas un principe d'égalité
c'est l'égalité réelle c'est pas
l'égalité par strates j'ai toujours de
la même façon sur quelle part est
décapitée s'est rétabli les égalités
l'égalité quand annick parent fait
aujourd'hui pour faire venir les jeunes
des communes a été fait sans s'en rendre
la première chance et que il revient aux
acteurs parlement lorsqu'il a donc pu
boire d'avoir le réflexe différenciation
première méthode aussi curieuse qu'elle
soit c'est avoir la foi
là - bas impossibles mois précise plus
haut niveau local on peut différencier
un exemple un c'est incroyable la police
administrative la crise m
par différenciation parce que c'est les
libertés publiques qui sont en cause
mais regardez l'article 2 du code
général des collectivités territoriales
commande des 10 et aujourd'hui j'avais
toujours été comme ça y est c'est vrai
quand il explique que les mères peuvent
pas rejoindre assurer une protection
dans aucune activité sécurité salubrité
publique minimum que l'exécutant il
expliqué difficile de faire aujourd'hui
une explosion combrée tout enfermé
insidious à la police administrative la
police a dû s'interposer libertés
publiques s'est différencié sur fontaine
vous avez des communes qui ont ressenti
le besoin de beaucoup d'autres pas du
tout pour nous tout simplement ans et
rex est patent de médiologie d'autres
ont tenté d art et systématique avec le
référé une vigne au tcbb dans la police
inquiet de savoir où cette confiance aux
affaires locales circonstances locales
première chose bords du loir la deuxième
chose pouvoir envoyer plus souvent au
pouvoir elle commence dans le cadre
les conseils constitutionnels de milieu
droit sur la force et c'est parti
permettez aux législateurs de renvoyer
pour certaines modalités d'application
de voir aux collectivités locales
dès lors qu'il s'agissait de dents en
cas dans leurs compétences et de leur
paie pas de mise en cause des libertés
que dès qu'une loi constitutionnelle les
droits constitutionnels
et quand on va aux collectivités pour
leur permettre d'élaborer un exemple de
différenciation par endroits qu'on
allait vers la démocratie proximité
devient tous deux toujours ça dépend
jusqu'en 2002 les anciennes aides
directes aux régions bien été fixée par
décret le premier c'est à dire aussi
harper reçoit l'ex région nantes
actionnaires devaient fournir des aides
directes dont la liste est fixée par le
premier ministre et chef juridique
quel est exactement les mêmes que celles
de l'ex renault pouvait alors que la
différence de situation économique est
énorme mais à partir de 2002 sans même
s'en rendre compte de ce qu'on a fait
eh bien on a renvoyé à l'assemblée
délibérante régional le soin de fixer
elle-même le régime
c est de l'assiette et un sud ne plus
avoir un politique de différenciation
des voix et non voix je pense que c'est
plus haut
local possède aussi fait valoir son
fonction publique territoriale dans une
salle de conférence et on peut aussi
n'étaient parfois pas toujours très
facile des doigts dans la loi anti
densifier les différences et prévoir
quelques solutions alternatives mais se
joint à les solutionner une chaussée en
fonction des circonstances et au bout du
déficit on peut obtenir les différences
de situation pour les compétences pour
les compétences qu'on est déjà couverte
dès 2004 en 2004 la loi a procédé à ce
qu'on appelait les avait la compétence
pour les fonds structurels
elle avait dit c'est la partie
département hélas pour les
infrastructures aéroportuaires en a
besoin d'eux on a dit del pilar animaux
collectivités territoriales à une
infrastructure sur son territoire
qu'elle est dictée d'ela clairement
envie alors qu'elle en a les moyens
despatis il ya plusieurs mois par le
préfet concernant et si bien le froid ou
thuram lui même qu il cassera
compétences et c'est ce que je crois ce
qu'on est en train de faire à dans une
loi en discussion concernant les
autorités et les autorités
organisatrices de mobilité on laisse la
possibilité de choix ça c'est la
différenciation y avait d'autres
possibilités
tout simplement pour les compétences la
différence de situation pris d'intérêt
général ou bien les deux tunnels servant
et productivité européenne d'alsace et
ce qui est intéressant c'est de procéder
à fonder que sur l'évidence de situation
ça se met aussi son intérêt général en
lien avec leur chat ta loi et ça c'est
une possibilité d'évolution
prenons un exemple medici pas là
sensation dans la différenciation des
compétences l'expérimentation
si on fait des représentations et qu'au
final on en une collectivité a
parfaitement réussi
140 et d'autre les failles des
compliments et bien mais si on arrive à
démontrer qu'une différence de situation
objective qui explique cette différence
est ce que le conseil d'état ne verra
pas un intérêt général en vie avec
l'objet d'allemand à ne pas forcer une
bonne activité à revenir en arrière sur
un parent de gestion qui n'est pas du
tout efficace autant le conseil
constitutionnel ne comptera pas deux
méthodes si une méthode est plus
efficace pour l'intérêt général que
l'autre il au sens humain jamais moi
mais revenons en arrière imposer une
sélectivité pour laquelle ça marchait
pas avant alors qu'elle a trouvé une
solution qui va revenir en arrière ça je
ne pense pas je pense que le bon sens
donc c'est tout à fait de voir l'intérêt
général autre exemple qui s' est aussi
lié à ces permis à la délégation de
compétence recourir plus à la délégation
de compétences et la possibilité d'avoir
du grain sans problème le régime
juridique est pas adapté porte on a
l'impression que tu t'es les ordres des
contrôles donné le la responsabilité ce
délégataire commis une imprudence
elle repose sur les éléments qu'il faut
arriver
la délégation la délégation c'est un bon
moyen d'avoir misé ans et sans
compétence sur le territoire et imagine
obtient au nom l'état les collectivités
les gazons compétences collectives et au
bout de quelques années on se rend
compte rapidement cette compétence est
mieux exercer au mieux une percée par la
connectique est ce que lui aurait pas
dans ce cas-là les autres n'est pas
question de leur accorder un intérêt
général de génois qui sera curieux cette
compétence suspens est effectivement
définitivement ce qu'on a trouvé une
méthode qui fonctionne à 45
il ya un intérêt général à ce point donc
vous voyez la différenciation vient n'a
pas constitutionnellement et de ce que
j'aime ici c'est plus de nouvelles sur
le faire la différenciation des
pressions et la différenciation
c'est pas le public elle fait en
cherchant conseil constitutionnel l'a
dit et 1995 c'est un moyen de réaliser
l'égalité et parfois recours à une ivg
stade sur sa foi dans la vie quotidienne
si vous avez un enfant pratique est un
peu mal à l'épaule qu'est ce qu'on fait
vous avez tous voté un tiers-temps
accordé à va pas à saisir
c'est assez grand parce que sinon on a
tous ratés ça nationale alors que pia
justement 10,4 en visite a réagi aussi
pour les connaissez mais pas seulement
dl santé handicap des handicapés qui
sont partis qui sont contraints un
visuel et c'est le résultat
et à la france si elle ne veut pas
obliger à 7 et différemment des
subventions aux pensées en effet lorsque
[Applaudissements]
vous restez avec nous dans la table
ronde et je vis kpan rejoint des élus
locaux en commençant par logic twitter
la présidente du conseil patronal du
robin ont évoqué dans le propos de
géraldine chabrier la collectivité
européenne la tasse
nous nous en parle gaulle et stéphane
perrin qui est rapporteur général du
budget du conseil régional de retables
demandé qu'un seul député du gers et
président de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation national romain
pasquier directeur recherche au cnrs
sciences po rennes voilà prenez place
messieurs et dames s'est passé son
studio
vous dites pourquoi faire sur le tir et
fictionnels et tout est possible on va
quand même essayer de voir comment
rendre les choses impossibles quand même
et avoir ebit à savoir si il faut
légiférer
il faut changer les choses mais pour
commencer vous propose que comme vous
l'avez fait on remarque de l'existant et
les commente au delà des locaux des
responsables de collectivités qui a
décidé de mettre en oeuvre de la
différenciation alors l'exemple le plus
récent plus frappants ça a été
effectivement la création de cette
collectivité européenne à face qui va
bientôt voir le jour
des réformes rondement menée qui était
de demande d'abord que les élus
alsaciens whitaker
mais merci à vous déjà pour une
agitation
je suis très heureuse expérience sociale
un an 23 septembre on parle pas c'est un
projet qui se construit
assez rapidement j'ai été voulu par
par qui a besoin d'alsace besoin
d'alsace qui est dû essentiellement à
destination de la grande région du
nord-est qui va devoir de parler
jusqu'au rhin et les alsaciens voilà je
suis dit hé bien la plus politique
alsace ça n'est pas possible il faut
dans cet espace particulier bassin géant
entre vosges et chance boire nous avons
des liens particuliers des liens très
forts avec vos voisins suisses
or la région on faisait regarder
beaucoup de gerland le voisin aussi du
territoire de belfort région mais ce
site en champagne avait un gars plus
alors qu'il ya justement de
différenciation par rapport à des
projets qui avait déjà
engagé comme la religion de deux
départements quatre nouveaux
départements s'agit pas quittée en kata
ce n'est pas une simple parce que pour
une simple fusion partement il aurait
suffit de voter des délibérations
concordantes entre les deux assemblées
dû avoir et du baroque comme le prévoit
le code général des collectivités
territoriales
en fait puisque nous apporte cette loi
ce qui a été reconnu par part et d'autre
part en très bien gérée par les deux
assemblées
ce sont des compétences qui nous vient
la fois de l'état et qui nous viennent à
la fois de la région ses compétences
répondent aux spécificités une
particularité de madame évidemment
souhaité mais c'est une première étape
et ses compétences
or ce qui était important pour nous
aussi ce n'était pas juste un retour à
l'alsace ce n'était pas un repli qui
perd a consciemment d'entités faire
c'était de se poser sur cette ouverture
à 360° de frappe et notamment vers ses
voisins suisses et c'est tout aussi
passionnant parce que le coeur du projet
c'est l'europe
alors certes l'alsace va être grâce à
cette loi du laboratoire de la
décentralisation une différenciation
et je l'espère d'autres territoires
pourront par la suite suivant bonal mais
nous sommes aussi nous voulons être
mamour avoirs européens et avec une
politique locale d'ailleurs d'autres
villes européennes
il ya eu local bord de janvier mais ça y
est on a cassé une taie damnation il ya
une nouvelle collectivité qui serait
extra territoriale
pas vraiment j'ai pris comme ça ça fait
un peu plus de deux ans qui présente une
partie vendue
jamais avant je n'aurais pensé au
quotidien mais vraiment au quotidien
nous avons des relations le voisin du
toit et sur des projets des projets
c'est par exemple le poste centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim
c'est par exemple la liaison ferroviaire
entre colmar fribourg avec la
reconstruction ne pense pas
et donc ça faisait sens et moi je ne
voyais vraiment pas avec les collègues
conseillers départementaux clair en
plongée juste en alsace ce projet
politique
c'est un projet qui se veut ouvert et
nous souhaitons que leurs sièges nommé
territoire et la france puisse puisse
être finalement danser merci au gpk
bordeaux
à des questions vous montrer ma pause r
je rappelle cet après midi est consacré
aussi aux échanges aux propositions que
vous pourrez faire sur le sujet et puis
aux questions que vous posez
légitimement alors intéressant parce
qu'on met le cap sur l'ouest et la
bataille n'était pas de peyrol là aussi
différenciation évoqué le pacte
d'accessibilité et puis les deux grandes
qui pour l'instant ne sont pas toutes
satisfaites du côté de conseil régional
de bretagne
si besoin à tous et merci lui n'ont
senti cette intiative j'excuse le vih
est déjà présent au concert genac qui
devait être présent mais qui ont retenu
par la commission des raisons c'est
d'être une doublure honorable là où il
est et je salue les nombreux élus
bretons mais ça minable et je pense
qu'un des faits françoise gatel des
biens très simplement dire que toulouse
est d'abord et peut-être à vous sans
partager
à siens nous sommes également une région
à forte identité
mais comme la cantine car tu as très
bien dit une somme par un réflexe
identitaire le sens très à l'aise la
république
et comme a dit présent d'archipel dans
son message ne s'agit pas de remettre
aux coups portés à un public
nous prions concerne j'ai d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion de le dire ne se trompe pas
les façons des timbres disparition
d'état il prend un président de la jeune
femme est aussi un préfet jeudi soir
forme besoin d'un comparse lui plus de
la région alors mal et arbore un préfet
a pris forme dès qu'ils aient
suffisamment de souplesse et qui
acceptent la confiance mais lequel car
le propre le premier reste c'est
peut-être déjà que l'état central face
prescience adaptable au qatar via un
nouveau concert en pleurant la vice
présidente
combien est parfois difficile d'obtenir
simplement que l'état local le préfet je
vais prendre un exemple je trouve que il
est d'actualité elle trouve qu'elle a
une fille brune un service inestimable
et ces derniers nous avons pu que
laisser tout le dispositif qui n'aiment
des constructions qui est un dispositif
qui repose sur les zonages qui ont été
définies dans l'incarnation
je trouve que l'an dernier il hommage
fini 4e seul le coeur de rennes
métropole et et gilou ça veut dire que
c'est catastrophique pour les autres
territoires
et c'est catastrophique pour la
métropole
on voit d'ailleurs la concentration se
faire sur ce plan il a fallu se battre
pour obtenir que soient définies
localement les ondes ne demandions pas
plus d'argent
nous utilisons entame de comptes publics
donnons simplement clé possibilités
d'adaptation locale
ça a été une bagarre titanesque à telle
enseigne qu entre produits évoluent
signé le contrat vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure qui inclut la deee ménagers
déchets autant ce qu'on vous à caen
s'était pas fait depuis philippe lemaire
mesurer un peu la révolution que sa
poursuite et ben ali parce que confier à
des élus locaux
même en coresponsabilité la main sur un
petit dépenses fiscales c'est quelque
chose de femmes dans une impasse et
malgré cette réalisation tout aille plus
faire part de l'administration centrale
pour récupérer ce qui nous avait été
accordé et prier que depuis jeudi
dernier que nous sommes en mesure de
dire qu'effectivement nous avons eu
possibilité d'adaptation
aucun de ce dispositif je dis parce que
c'est là c'est grâce à la ministre
gouraud que nous y sommes arrivés juste
à saluer comme je salue les sénateurs de
tous les banques sur ce point
c'est l'évidence mais c'est pas parce
que c'est l'évidence que ça paraît
naturel et qu'il n'y a pas de résistance
au niveau licence
encore une fois il s'agit simplement de
dire que les hommages vont être décidées
dans un comité d'habitat qui est présidé
par le préfet région avec des
représentants des différentes
collectivités ou this omar encore
fallait-il que l'état permette et ça a
été encore une fois quelque chose qui a
été conquis donc quand vous à mon
travail ici sujet de différenciation le
dispositif est un sujet n'avons pas
d'effets de mouvement nous sommes pas
passés dans une posture de demander une
révision constitutionnelle d'arriver à
un grand soir constitutionnel qui a très
bien le montrer qu'il y avait déjà
beaucoup de possibilités donc nous
allons constituer un groupe de travail
de serge ibaka produit un certain nombre
de propositions
je n'ai pas toutes les gagner mais qui à
chaque fois sont des propositions qui
donne le droit comprend permettent tout
à fait de prévoir l'une soit une
délégation de compétence soit 1,4 à la
main du préfet à la main et
collectivités nous avons plus ça change
revoir cpap qui fonctionne extrêmement
bien en bretagne très grande
participation de l'ensemble
donc c'est ça nous sommes comportés nous
on n'a pas un vrai chat noir porté
atteinte à la république mais c'est vrai
que j'en suis peut-être nous avons
obtenu il ya quelques années déjà une
délégation sur la gestion de certains
clients en matière de culture
lorsque cette délégation nous a été
accordé des crédits en entamant géré par
la drac qui sont désormais
lorsque nous avons obtenu cette
délégation d une dispense à distance
après diverses elles peuvent être des
résistances y compris des usagers
je renvoie une tribune assez étonnant
qui parle dans le monde redoute de robin
renucci
ils s'inquiètent de voir les locaux
prendre la main en matière de forage en
france mais il semble considérer si les
locaux ce pays de cultures ne savent pas
faire la différence entre divertissement
et culture un peu tout mélanger j'étais
un peu surpris de ce discours mais même
en interne dans les administrations
centrales
on nous a expliqué que nous risquions de
porter atteinte au siège d'eda
république
songez que les crises application ces
cinq cent mille euros
si nous arrivons à mettre à rêver mis
par terre
samir on sait qu à répliquer bien malin
est dans le doute c'est quand même temps
et ça fait écho à se mobiliser votre
collègue brigitte sy cas il y à un
consensus
du côté des deux élus locaux quand il
s'agit de demander d'éducation
d'affirmer une différence quels que
soient les niveaux à après la question
c'est est ce que l'opinion est d'accord
que l'on s'organise aussi cette
évolution
et là je me tourne vers une impasse rica
car avantage d'être votre mot patriote
vous venez on va leur montrer ce qu'ils
enseignent à son secours al merrikh un
bon directeur de recherche au cnrs
comment vous voyez vous présenter tout à
l'heure quelques résultats d'un sondage
a été commandé par le groupe de 1906 et
quand on demande aux français ce qui
s'ils sont prêts à des évolutions
quand on leur dit à propos des
collectivités locales françaises fautifs
ce sont plutôt les réformes en
profondeur mais maintenir en l'état ou
adapter leur organisation transformer
radicalement
on a une majorité de compatriotes qui
sont favorables à cette adaptation à
cette évolution et la paix d'allah la
réponse est encore plus forte quand on
parle de communes nouvelles
nos concitoyens sont plutôt positifs
quand il s'agit d'affirmer des
différences à déterminer
oui parce que toutes les personnes qui
répondent véritablement une opinion sur
dix n'ont dit le mesurent les
conséquences éventuelles
je me rappelle les collègues
britanniques qui ont étudié et parce
qu'ils ont des vraies idoles tic de la
réforme qui oublie pendant dix ans les
conséquences de la demo che est
originaire pour lui 10 15 ans parce
qu'on posait la question des caniveaux
et faussaire vous gloire est ce que vous
brûlez plus de compétences et toujours
lui ai alors leur pause un deuxième défi
est ce que vous voulez être traité
différemment selon les territoires et là
souvent la réponse est non on veut plus
de pouvoir mais on ne veut pas un niveau
de service public différent d'un
téléphone là il ya quand même un blocage
culturel local je vivais politique qui
va ici notion d'aidé lorsqu'on avait
fait des sondages à peu près équivalent
en 2010 avant la crise
maja qu'on a connu une baisse de
notation en france les réponses des
pralines elle était aussi un peu près
les mêmes en espagne grand pays
l'autonomie locale et
en france il faut quand même se méfier
moi je pense que si on va la
différenciation si on reste dans nos
schémas que l'on connaît aujourd'hui on
peut se dire en délire nous a répondu
constitutionnel on sait déjà faire on a
fait je pense que ça risque d'être assez
décevant
je suis favorable et une vision beaucoup
plus ambitieux moi je pense que ça ça
suppose de changer de logiciel à la
commande de chance on ne le changera pas
sans révision constitutionnelle et 100
nouveaux partages de la puissance us
donc il faut se poser à m trois
questions
première question c'est quelle valeur
ajoutée pour la différenciation est ce
que c'est une belle robe pour qui et
pourquoi
deuxième question c'est comment on
partage il parce que enfin on reste sur
un modèle ou proto modo la capacité d'un
natif des élus locaux - l'exception deux
de trois exemples elle rappelle en
france en comparaison de des grands pays
européens qui se sont engagés dans la
campagne
donc nos élus locaux ne sont pas
habitués à fabriquer la partager la
puissance publique adapté sur un
territoire des lois créées des
règlements locaux
sachant qu un autre logiciel c'est pas
simplement le logiciel de la
décentralisation 82 83 qui d'un coup on
fait des collectivités locales des
opérateurs de politique uniquement dans
le logiciel aura bien des décideurs
c'est pas la créativité politique la
créative et institutionnelle qui est le
moteur donc la différenciation son
barbuda de la logique a glissé avant les
fédérales un cancer
car les soins un autre registre à
larsson qui viennent et par étapes
mehdi fouet elle presse est ce qu'on est
prêt à cela devient un gars dont l'unité
de la république aux menaces comme l'a
indiqué le président larcher on est
capable de véritablement construit une
gouvernance à s'endormir par simplement
descendante
moi j'en doute encore un peu un jour
deux encore un peu en tout cas si on
veut aller assez loin
si on veut aller plus loin que de
simples délégation compétence de l'état
si on si on veut aller un peu plus loin
que ces expériences intéressantes et
quand même qui demande une énergie folle
pour être appliquée il va falloir une
révision constitutionnelle
et là je crois que si on va dans cette
direction là effectivement on change de
logiciel mais là les vétos politique se
regroupent plus important parce qu'on
lève dans un modèle historique qui est
marqué par une très forte d'actifs
merci on va passer alors les gros mots
ont été prononcés ne sais pas si on veut
faire de la différenciation pour faire
du fédéralisme qu'en pensez vous jean
rené cazeneuve vous qui présidé la
délégation collectivités territoriales
et à la décentralisation à l'assemblée
nationale et je rappelle que votre
délégation a déjà commencé à travailler
sur ces sujets justement dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes rentré dans cette
pensée projet
absolument je suis entouré de bretons
dont les réseaux sont aussi possibles de
hier soir je suis assez d'accord
explique un des aspects ça parce qu'il a
de dire c'est à dire que effectivement
maintenant que j'avais la tête ailleurs
aujourd'hui la réaction peu plus loin en
matière de différenciation et alice est
souhaitable et les élus sont très
favorables maison c'est l'aube allemand
sans véritable proposés sont très
favorables à cette découverte est ce
qu'il faut faire beaucoup plus
je dis oui il faut y aller fonçons et
quand on regarde pas même le résultat
depuis un certain temps et
différenciation il est possible depuis
2004 donc en 15 ans l'élu leur principe
est un peu différent parce que c'était
expérimentation sur l'ol soit à
l'abandon soit la généralisation des
plus une préfiguration quand on regarde
les comptes au regard de résultats je
crois qu a eu à peu près 1000 15ème
d'expérimentation qui sont allés au
monde un échec tout à fait tout à fait
relatif donc fait qu'on est mené sur peu
de jours que aujourd'hui la
différenciation est possible vous l'avez
exprimés pour être encore des voyants
très nombreuses mais
pratique et c'est une vérité
d'expression dans notre pays pourquoi
pour eux dr raisons la première est
expliqué et c'est à dire que soit les
français attendent de la différenciation
et en même temps dès qu'ils ont pas
exactement là où le voisin salue ainsi
sa part de venir et j'avais je rencontre
des gens qui me disent que je comprends
pas reste à charge de mon département
si je fais 5 km où j'ai pas là n'est pas
le même mais ça ne va pas leur
différenciation d'une petite élite en
été différenciés
prenez 90 m étais par commande peuvent
l'adapter aux pour être aux côtés d'un
certain nombre en permettant et là nous
a quittés qu'elle la responsabilité qui
va être engagée s'il est vrai que rapide
et l'exigence sociale insiste un peu
aussi simple que ça pour toujours prend
- vraiment qu'il faut aller plus loin
aux aresquiers là dessus je crois que la
constitution voir évoluer ou facilité
protéger un peu plus les élus qui vont
aller vers la réforme prochaine telle
qualité proposés alors effectivement je
cautionnais en profite
j'espère que les sénateurs vont enfin
rendre des réformes constitutionnelles
et ils vont nous aider à facettes et
quand ça se passe t il est primordial
que l'uniformité et aristote au
déploiement des politiques publiques
dans une telle foi et donc si on
n'accepte pas cet élément de
différenciation et on sera même si on
peut faire plus de choses évidemment
on sera toujours limité à dire de la
spécialité en matière de lisibilité
avait bien demandé et je t'avais
religieuse ce qui est proposé par arc en
ciel aujourd'hui maxime tout devient pas
autorisé journaux membres pas faire
n'importe quoi donc on respecte
évidemment elle est assise pour tout
dire merci j'envie 15,9 alors a terminé
le tour de table en venant avec vous
j'ai rapide chabrier vous savez que on
évoque alain stoll l'expérimentation au
modèle
2004 il s'agit de montrer ses limites
juste au moment où celui ci
oui il a pu se montre ces joutes en
suspens comment vous arrivez l'ensemble
des expérimentations transfert de
compétences ou l'expérimentation
dérogation la norme dans les 101 ans en
a deux et pro-serbe compétences support
d'expérimentation appréciable
d'expérimentation méthodes d'évaluation
derrière la plupart du temps n'était pas
sur le vide et d'expérimentation et
justement du coup ça me permet faire
arbitres donnent entendre les
fermentations réviser la constitution
et vous avez vu ce que ça donne donc je
suis d'accord pour dire que la
différenciation
il faut réviser la constitution parce
symboliquement il faut l'affirmer
maintenant c'est amusant que ce soit moi
qui le dit mais c'est un peu un fantasme
de professeur de droit que penser que
parce qu'on révise la constitution on va
changer de logiciel on va appliquer le
13 mai devant la révision
constitutionnelle mars 2003 avec son
devoir et un commentaire locales affirmé
son expérimentation et sert à ça a donné
ça n'a rien de bio il faut changer les
mentalités
j'ai encore pas tous mais comment
changer les mentalités mais je vous
changer
alité plutôt de changer les normes pour
autant oui il faut réviser la discussion
parce qu'il ya quand même quelque chose
qui va pas dans cette constitution c'est
que l aide de 1958 moi je suis tout
contente
cette stabilité fait pas partie de ce
clan du domaine mais 158 les
collectivités territoriales c'était et
donc quand on avait fléchi à la
répartition des normes
on s'est fait une résolution on sépare
pas la loi avoir un domaine limité
et qu'est-ce que sur les mythes le
domaine qui va bénéficier de ce pouvoir
et semble même le premier ministre
appelle dans la rue à aucun moment ses
dix balles collectif aussi c'est ce qui
distingue fondamentalement les la france
les autres sait pas c'est que le pouvoir
imputé formule 1 c'est pas grand chose
je crois savoir que en allemagne
l'urbanisme les légistes et nous on voit
réglementaire beaucoup en fait on a
quand même la compétence ioniques et
faut pas trop réfléchir comme ça il faut
juste le dire qu'elle est effectivement
une partition normatives dans la
constitution française
elle est la trace d'une répartition qui
a eu lieu quand les collectivités
organisée oui il faut qu'elle ait faut
plus merci alors que chip leader et je
posais la même question à cette école
terrain quand on veut tuer les locaux ne
sont pas habitués à créer de la langue
et puis cet équilibre entre la dame nord
mais les mentalités l'acceptation
sociale
l'harmonisation des traités
belle mise en oeuvre produits janvier
tiens je peux dire que avec la grande
majorité des élus alsaciens qui nous
attend dans la réforme constitutionnelle
parce que la loi les a c'est une étape
importante et du châtelet d'ailleurs
derrière parce que j'ai pas l'attendre
tous à leurs compétences que nous avons
tendance à sa place comme en mai mais
ces deux mois alsace et pourrait pour
voir une première dans les wc étapes
suivantes ne pourront se faire que grâce
à la constitution que je voudrais
souligner aussi parce que nous sommes
ici pour cela c'est le parcours
législatif tout à fait remarquable de
cette fois encore a peur rapide cinq
mois entre la science et des ministres
et la pulsion d'abord la promulgation
ensuite les deux assourdir enrichit le
tat est ce qu'on est arrivé sans
reproduire tout à fait équilibrée et
plus surtout ces lois particulières
goûter 80% par le sénat et 4e voire 14%
parlement national c'est énorme
la majorité l'opposition les compétences
parce que je crois que c'est important
ce sont des compétences que nous avons
demandé la première services d'archivés
transfrontalier évidemment aux quotas
avec la mise en oeuvre par la collecte
qui terrasse du schéma de coopération
transfrontalière la deuxième compétences
très importantes c'est bilinguisme aux
côtés de l'éducation nationale la
politique va pouvoir développer
son nom recruter des appartements parce
qu'on le sait beaucoup d'éducation
nationale en longues bandes troisième
compétences très important pour moi le
transfert des routes nationales et
autoroutes concédées avec la possibilité
pour la collecte qui menace de mettre en
place une régulation du trafic de poids
lourds en transit et puis pour notre
compétence encore mais 17 de résumer
dans ce qu'elle la région l'attractivité
et le tourisme la destination
touristique vraiment c'est un projet qui
était portée par l'ensemble des élus
alsaciens et vous savez le droit la
différenciation froid répond pierre
aussi aux demandes eux qui sont
aujourd'hui celles de nos concitoyens
c'est la flexibilité la subsidiarité
c'est d'efficacité à savoir qu'on sait
c'est répondre en fait l'un des enjeux
locaux
c'est aussi la citoyenneté parce qu'on a
avec la loi les as des élus de proximité
qui s'il est élu et reconnu et fut
chaque territoire
le vrai potentiel qui sont les siens au
service nature et sa 106 merci alors la
même question à stéphane perrin sur la
capacité sur la réponse des élus locaux
a créé de la gare et puis ensuite
on réagit aux intervenants je crois
qu'il ya un micro qui va circuler en jeu
manqua qu'écrit lose it et des cours je
rejoins à ces jardins du jazz sur
l'impact vers la maison chanel qui
peut-être les bras des obstacles
psychologiques c'est certain et qui ne
fera pas tout je vais prendre un exemple
peut-être est-ce une réponse à jean rené
cazeneuve
on est en plein dans une très grande
région agricole à voltaire et qui est
confronté à des sujets transition
majeure parce qu du monde allez une
telle pause on ne parle aujourd'hui leur
demande aujourd'hui de renationalisation
de la gestion du club
et quand on explique on a été plusieurs
à faire des listes que nous en géant ou
le seul le deuxième pilier naval celui
qui permet justement d'accompagner les
agriculteurs à 30 c est que ce serait
catastrophique cette
professionnalisation
qu'est ce qu'on voudrait coudes et tout
ce qu'ils chantent des gens qui sont sur
les terrains ne pas citer nommé qui sont
des gens équilibrés
[Musique]
en tout cas moi j'en ai parlé avec arrêt
et qu est ce qu on me répond on répond à
mes principes d'égalité et on y revient
comment imaginez-vous qu'on traite
différemment un agriculteur breton de
l'agriculteur d'un autre territoire
mais la réalité c'est pouces c'est
aujourd'hui la reine que la dignité et l
est et n'est pas respectée avec le
revenu des agriculteurs bretons est
inférieur à celui de la table bon
deuxième chose on nous dit avait imaginé
une région développe une politique
agricole qui soit en contre en
contradiction avec les objectifs que le
gouvernement développe par exemple un
texte badauds et des terres qu'on
imagine tout de suite la collectivité
comme un contre-pouvoir comme un
empêcheur mais nous disons principes
essentiels le contraire et c'est pour ça
que le plan concerne la langue et la
régionalisation de tous les fonds apax
en plus ils ont été remarquablement mal
gérée avec des logiciels qui ne
fonctionnait pas commis les agriculteurs
comme dans les difficultés terribles
moi je fais le pari que si demain on
confie des responsabilités aux
collectivités ça sera pas seulement des
gains concept et ça sera des gaves est
déficient aucune déficience et donc je
vois qu'il ya encore quand même des
obstacles culturels
je pense que l'art via la cohésion entre
les élus en tout cas où tonna en
bretagne je pense aussi qu'on a pas de
réticence à produire et à produire des
cartes
à terme ces verts ont fini par lui
répondre
lorsque on est à bout d'arguments
arrivez-vous en bretagne ça marche bien
et qui sanctionne
mais c'est pas partout pareil donc on ne
sait pas chez lui dire ceux qui ont sont
en capacité à hausser les alsaciens ou
montré incapable d'avancer
nous on fait les propositions de kara
lancée permettant à ceux qui sont en
capacité de faire d'avancé en bretagne
n'a encore une fois quelques exemples de
réussite contre permettait une
simplement de continuer à avancer
évidemment connaître de tous les
territoires ne sont pas au même degré de
maturité sur tous les sujets mais de
grâce de grâce qu'on nous permette de
faire je vous jure que les est encore
une fois au cas les différentes
sensibilités
je reprends sommes disponibles pour les
sénateurs bretons de tous les pans
consignes commune
laissons faire de punition par nombreux
sont ceux qui va avancer tams et la
région soupçonné maintenant c'est un
outil à mon avis encore la foire elle
permet de lever des obstacles qui
conjugue des prétextes notamment
l'invocation abusive du principe d été
et je pense que surtout du fou que
l'état d'esprit change dans une
administration centrale et que les
ministres qui ont été des élus locaux
recouvre la mémoire et conçoit
jusque 2,3 et pas fier sujet des élus
locaux qu'à ce qu'ils demandent ils
demandent de la liberté d'agir et les
inouk ont sont tout à fait prêts à
prendre des responsabilités et toute la
responsabilité
c'est là leur demande essentielle il
s'agit pas généré de normes nationales
par contre que la norme nationale arrête
de brider d'action conseillers des
propos qui a évoqué suite un accord pour
deux personnes deux autocrates
génétiques ont fait aujourd'hui en 2009
vous êtes obligés et les maires ont été
représentés à la fois que la dépouille
[Musique]
près la possibilité est évidemment
liberty commune et on ne les voie
juridique à cet hiver donc la très
divers la nécropole de diot ne seront
plus représentés c'est aussi de vous
aurez votre chef de l'opposition qui lui
sera sans doute durable et élevée qu'au
but il n'aura pas très télé je trouve ça
scandaleux je le dis j'ai d'ailleurs ce
cas cela reste un détenu nous
positionner gentilshommes cette
nouveauté est cette chose ex ddaf ans au
pupitre et jules est reçue avec cette
loi vient alors mais si je peux le voir
dans lequel arrivent sur tout ce qui lui
serait de revoir le modèle de base afin
que les maires des communes qui sont la
proximité soit représentée au sein des
jours qui séparent les équipes nous
savons nous sommes muscles et les nerfs
la plupart des blessés je ne veux pas de
votre constat 13 mai
[Applaudissements]
d'autres interventions des manèges des
messieurs et puis depuis ce temps
bonjour didier sénéchal je suis mère
dans la région rennaise au jeu
stéphanois préalable une certaine
compréhension de ce qu'est dj acier
concernant les locaux qui visent à la
télé dans que ce soit au niveau jeu
l'apparition de ce train local les spots
au niveau communal
dominique un bas niveau cache pas son
ancien fiancé
si les quotidiens que dit le comte et
l'adapter attendent toujours mouche a
piqué g vous avez dit à un moment donné
trois points qu'il faut que la loi soit
point de possibles et elles sucent pas
qu'on est tous d'accord
on a tous eu ducati 1000 watts la
culture de cette cinquième est beaucoup
plus beau couple aussi le problème
sur son corps les stratégistes quoique
quelques forces pour appliquer dans
toute équité paul delevoye qu'il est
question par les parlementaires cotation
[Musique]
qui ici peut le combattre je le cite un
exemple le cynisme en collectif la loi
n'a pas transmis l'assainissement
collectif
il commente je dis pas qu'elle avait un
recours devant le tribunal administratif
pour y inclure les et un registre un
concept qui va effectivement que
l'europe et l'assainissement collectif
au motif que quelques voix avant chanel
co lauréate a subi ensuite la loi
d'autorisation la pensée comment 50
sagesse
chiche 69 comment avoir des lois et
faire en sorte qu'à des registres à
disparaître d'internet et spebio ont
encore des sous pour ses pions
[Musique]
aujourd hui nous sommes à la fois un jeu
à la fois au port de saint malo et la
montante de la construction ce qui tombe
directement à remettre les élus locaux
au coeur de décisions et en tout cas au
coeur de décision de prendre à venir
bien longtemps un sujet qui est
malheureusement écartée pour des
institutionnels ce jour mes joueurs que
nous partie cette aussi du show plus
changé sur ce terrain là qui concerne
directement la république en cas la
responsabilité des élus
comment est il possible aujourd'hui au
niveau de l'organisation des eaux
je élément qui permet de répartir les
sièges dont sept seulement retenu soit
la population du territoire le bc dif et
que la commune centre dispose de 50
enfants d'époque de recettes assemblée
et que de surcroît lorsque je passais du
représentant le maire de gruissan et en
même temps donc cumuler le plus âgé des
finances indien
je m'en fous locaux et bureaux de cette
chance de comprendre
présentation et comment peut-on
expliquer à nos concitoyens aux
prochaines élections qui m'a soufflé
chez nous la lui d'y pêcher représentant
devions à l'europe que on hésite avant
le maire commune en place n'en a qu'une
loi et ne ploie exprimé aucun pouvoir
ici dans des situations de votants s'est
beaucoup attaché uniquement aux nouveaux
habitants
et pourquoi en dit long aussi une
réponse pour les deux interpellations
qui concerne la gouvernance locale
comment la différencier d'abord on va
parce qu'ils essaient des sujets que
vous suivez de près tout ce qui a fait
que démocratie locale
cette gouvernance et on voit bien la
quantité ce prix est aussi
la différenciation de l'exaspération oui
je les amis proches j'entends
effectivement les problématiques de
l'articulation entre les opci et les
communes
je suis dans le regret de dire qu on a
40% de communes et que donc que tous les
pays européens tous les pays occidentaux
ont réformé leur carte communale depuis
le début des années 70 ça pose des
problèmes aujourd'hui j'en suis
conscient que je suis je suis d'accord
que ça fausse d'une série difficulté de
le la times amis de l'intercommunalité
c'est à dire le fait de contourner la
réforme de la fable la carte communale
on en essayant de développer la
coopération il s'engage et la légitimité
démocratique au fonctionnement complet
de pci ça pose des difficultés majeures
petit maire qui sont comprises et avoir
c'est à dire que ils sont confrontés
vrai qu'ils sont interpellés par leurs
administrés et qui n'ont plus les moyens
de combien les politiques publiques à la
mesure de leur interpellation
l'articulation démocratie continue mais
que ce problème là ne masque pas l'autre
problème on a plus de communes que les
états unis
messieurs robert sait que la prônait
c'est qu'on a quand même on est à 100%
d'ubi monde est unique
[Musique]
j'habite chez gd interpellation qui sont
garantes des adaptations d'abord une
réponse
on a plus de liberté contre la loi on
n'a pas véritablement relais de relève
le juge elle nous indique interprète
intentions du législateur
il peut effectivement selon le
directoire interprétation différente
mais si on organise un envoi pouvoir
réglementaire des collectivités locales
le juge sera tenue normalement cette
définition
c'est à dire que la légalité la lecture
et dispositif c'est la loi tel que
précisé non plus par décret du premier
ministre mais par l'arrêté locale
il va suspect riffier que l'arrêté au
calme est conforme aux principes
législatifs france est bon que ça
normalement sa règle nos problèmes alors
gouvernance locale et différenciation
vous poser une question à laquelle je
pense autant son temps j'allais le temps
de passer beaucoup de temps je me
demande effectivement j ch.b telle chute
je suis bien je suis les centres et du
coup aujourd'hui j'entends ce que dit
mon collègue basque
et j'entends aussi seconde ici et me
dans ce cas là je me demande quand même
s'il n'y a pas quelque chose qui va pas
avec cette lecture de la constitution
qui est essentiellement démographiques
effectivement c'est quand même quelque
chose qui va et je crois qu'il faudrait
effectivement si on avait une révision
constitutionnelle écrire quelque chose
pour que ce soit un acte simple ce soit
souple mais attention parce que c'est
dangereux
[Musique]
la constitution ne doit le juge ahmed
baba rome consacre décorum on rajoute un
détail vous êtes très attention parce
qu'on peut créer beaucoup de
complications à partir la norme
fondamentale
voudrait il faut y réfléchir à mon avis
vous une belle étude sur le sujet voir
si on peut pas trouver une formulation
qui fasse entrer effectivement la
diversité des collectivités des
territoires dans la définition plutôt
que des prévisions sur l'équipe
démographique chance que là c'est vrai
plus à faire entendu pendant le
calendrier la révision constitutionnelle
encore que justice lui quel calendrier
la cote est de tenter
centralisation des concentrations
différenciation diversité dans les tops
oui je suis juré répondre présent
dimanche prochain
je dirais les histoires d'amitié ainsi
que le chemin qu'il fallait le poser
l'état et collectivités territoriales
laissait souvent un n'était tribune mais
si on veut transformer le pays
absolument le faire ensemble et opposés
l'un à l'autre ne paraît pas raisonnable
il faut absolument déterminés au joli a
trop recoupements et c'est vrai les
accords entre les responsabilités donc
un travail de clarification des
responsabilités entre ces différents
minogue est tout à fait essentiel il ya
aussi je crois que le mieux c'est de
faire ensemble l'éviter imaginez que
votre enfant ce sont aussi les régions
parce que décentralisation ça n'est pas
simplement quelles sont les compétences
que les tableaux région ça se passe très
bien en bretagne
formidable moi je peux vous dire que mon
paysans du fezensac quand il s'agit
d'aller à la rsv à montpellier et à
l'impression que montpellier c'est au
moins un an j moins que l'état donc vous
avez aussi au sein dirigeantes des
sujets pour savoir quel est le bon
niveau de subsidiarité
elle prodigue aux délégations comme on
voudrait recréer aussi des régions en
question un peu plus folk eux mêmes
travers que l'état français a eu pendant
quelques siècles
attention de trouver un jour seulement
les politiques et des super six
évidemment les les maires et sont comme
vous savez de fait essentielle à notre
goût leur point répondait à renwez ego
et les je tablerais là tu sais qu'il ya
deux mois qu'ils sont en discussion et
car il avait présenté tout à l'heure que
votre introduction il ne s'appelle
engagement et profiter des élus qui doit
redonner du pouvoir
mr qui doit redonner rééquilibrer au
sein des paisibles ma question de
détricoter les epci qui va redonner un
peu de latitude
je vous encourage à vous manifester la
loi et tout cela d'ici quelques semaines
françoise était le rapporteur de ce
texte on peut elle nous écoutera
l'espagne effectivement l'objet de cette
fois que leur et qu'ils aimeraient un
petit peu au profit des nerfs remercier
entendu au sein des epc et pour qu'on
ait une démocratie locale plus plus plus
fort de cette fois doigt raconte en
particulier un 59e joue donc sa 3ds et
pc assez simple l'occident qu'on peut
jeter une pierre à cette majorité
cynisme qui ne comprennent pas mais
c'est notre majorité qui veut proposer
une nouvelle loi pour une étape
supplémentaire de la descendre
on a cette volonté de répondre aux
attentes de ses premiers couacs on n'a
pas le faire vendre des choses c'est un
sujet trop doit avant tout un combat
législatif puisque il faut le faire
sereinement et sa soif et après
municipal vraiment et de faire après le
bac des compagnies nation et on met en
valeur les bières de la différenciation
occasion de distributeurs question de
vos confrères patrick roger jean les
cases ne pas évoquer effectivement là ce
qu'on appelle le 3 d acidité concernant
sa survie j'ai l'impression qu'on est
actuellement dans un entre deux entre
une expérimentation pour géraldine
chabrières rappelé qu' elle n'a pas
vraiment fonctionné et une
différenciation dont plusieurs
intervenants ont estimé que sa nécessité
une révision constitutionnelle mais
révision constitutionnelle qui pour
l'instant restent hypothétiques pour
toute une série de raisons politiques
je prends savoir que le gouvernement a
saisi le conseil d'état pour savoir
s'ils n'étaient pas possible d'étendre
les possibilités d'expérimentation et
que le conseil d'état devrait rendre son
avis le 1er octobre justement ce
sur ce sujet et moi j'aimerais bien
savoir ce que les intervenants attendent
de cet avis du conseil d'état est ce que
eux-mêmes envisage une extension du iii
d'expérimentation art défaut de
différenciation des roquettes
surviennent quand on veut dire la vérité
et ostrava un avis et un rapport vous
avez six demandes j'étais membre de ce
comité et donc les bretons bien monsieur
et dément également on n'a pas forcément
au niveau des paroles parler avant le
conseil d'état mais tout ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'on était dans une
interprétation dynamique des choses et
combattu dans le sens d'une
simplification espérait pas tant qu'il
tient dans la communication officielle
du conseil d'état
en tout cas ce que je fais là s'est
personnellement a jugé t il avant de
répondre à cet automne oui mais oui à la
communauté et les gens vers les peuples
qui s'appellera bien regroupé trois
communes c'est là que l'était comme on
entre par titre
d'abord toute façon il n'ya pas régulier
des commandes de france le temps
pluvieux 1992 et je fus un petit jeune
qui amène l'eau des nappes ont des
mentalités
le batave 17 contre les colts ont été
d'abord une demi finale aussi folle
s'est élargi en 96 pour rire communauté
comme une toile foot et drew a conçu
également et nous avons dès 1980
quatorze bateaux dans la première il y
avait un réseau communautaire
un caporal alpha chaque commune autour
de lui pour le faire puisque les verts
font les bonnes nouvelles on se vouvoie
il a reçu plus mortelle dans la
solidarité mais oblige temps d'échanger
quelques mots hors de portée venant
michaud politiques sont venus pratiquer
avec brio je vous le dis
en disant j'ai un million d'habitants le
deuxième au tableau des 15 900 habitants
et on voyait les 450 habitants et deux
premières fois même communauté connut
jamais connues ces logos au mur des
pommes et communautaire je lui ai bien
petit chien on n'a pas voulu d'un couple
au thé où il y avait une commune de 350
le tassement 2010
[Musique]
le maire n'a pas été consultée au
téléphone et qui te renvoie réputation
[Musique]
et juste au côté exotique comme une
simplification
pour cette saison sachant comment
terminer sa première passe en général je
fais référence le sénateur référence à
un concept différent qui ne souffre pas
mélanger légalité et d'identité
donc nous sommes tous égaux devant la
loi au niveau territorial identique à
son arc une lecture du territoire à
travers plusieurs reprises sa manette la
géographie l'histoire la sociologie des
drones riesch elle reprend l on ne rame
pas donc plusieurs disent voyez cette
loi de type la vision d'un avenir flou
pour ses tares et un restaurant devient
différencier st et puis vous parlez en
paiement aller vers un modèle allemande
si vous voulez mais ce qui m'ennuie
c'est que nous aussi on est un terreau
connais pas des citoyens qui nous disent
les taxes que ces tirs dans certains cas
joue-t-il toujours son rôle régalien but
est aussi de bien définir le rôle
véritable nom
les gagnants je prends un exemple les
terrains
j'ai même arrêté avec un an avant je
remercie et l'égalité on est tous égaux
devant les foules et un monde neuf dans
dix sites sont incorrectes ou si vous
êtes donc si des noms n'ont qu'à pas
d'identité
il n'a pas eu d'incidence dans les
jambes mais certaines très régulièrement
à la mairie l'on soit plus de jambes sur
les pratiques évidemment son rôle est
d'alerter et c'est très important
ensuite vous avez parlé burns par les
enfants
je peux me dire 494 opposa on a refait
des siennes
il ya deux local de l'habitat des
histoires imaginaires de les aider à
faire un certain que l'état de ces
normes
à lesparre il est at il dit
c'est toujours le même combat
eni girondins d'ici d'ailleurs qu'est ce
qu'il a fait il a créé des agences
cantournet détroit mène un peu
importants à cause de nous les élus la
main la survie des petites communes
et puis tous les sociologues les airs
bonjour et rappelé les gens qui viennent
de métropole le bas du dos je sors je
pense que c'était une excellente
transition avec la deuxième partie de
trucs colloque justement puisque à la
pop telle différenciation et république
décentralisée
on va regarder justement que mon père me
voir tout cela en remercions
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant à nous rejoindre lors
de ce scrutin
[Musique]
je
mais
nous a rejoint en tant que l'évasion
erik orsenna de l'académie mais plus
vert et or celle à qui et je dirai dans
un short ou des thèmes beaucoup aidé
pour cette activité alors vous le dire
les conseillers d'état qui connaît bien
les développer
je me dis stration des territoires de
l'état dans cet intéressant
jai alai d'avoir votre éclairage à ce
moment
soit parce que normalement la station de
pousser pour l'ancien analysable
compréhension c'est en creux
j'accompagne d'ailleurs avec un certain
nombre de jeux disputés du cepici et non
simplement vers la green team
c'est une chronique parce que il ya les
objectifs contradictoires tout se voir
mais le preneur du business y retourne
parce que
la question c'est loin finalement de ce
partage de responsabilités mais c'est à
la fois la puissance et de transferts à
d'autres responsabilités
c'est aussi ma là pour l'état je me
souviens dans des bars les
revendications c'était le sabbat qui est
des tables parise et celui ci il est
question sur les agences parce que il ya
des concentrations de l'état c'est assez
facile à passer le bébé pendant alors
c'est pas moi c'est l'autre et la
multiplication des salles ans c'est pas
comme ça qu'on faire l'état
s'établissent ainsi l'état après la
centralisation la paire de sandales
vinification au quart de poil mais je
sais pas le sujet français alors que
j'aime bien en tant que reporter et là
je sais plus en temps en temps quand il
se trouve que quand j'étais 17 ans j'ai
rejoint un truc s'appelle déçu pour des
raisons très simples de chamonix c'est à
dire je voyais une seule planète le
biais de youtube qui arrivent elles
répondent ans et je suis dit c'est s'il
n'arrive pas la développer
ça va chauffer vos images et exactement
soixante ans après la même fournisseur
c'est à dire que milliards
france qui s'éclate à grande vitesse
d'une et j'ai vu ça depuis longtemps
parce que comme je suis humain et y
emmener vos enfants j'ai des frères et
donc mieux je bats le parcours en france
anciennement nationalité donc j'ai bien
de partout la patiente et comme j'ai
reçu de mission pour développer à
l'utopie mais j'étais en 55 est encore à
rochefort où il y avait 250 responsables
de l'umih la tête de tout plein de
l'habitacle
ça s'appelait initiatives dans le milieu
headley et ceux qui le fera ces deux
mécanismes concomitants le premier les
deux francs six étapes à grande vitesse
l'une de l'autre et on peut vraiment pas
dire que les liégeois est surpris car
avec une autre couleur c'est pas régi la
musique et des bonnets les idées rouge
on a vécu exactement la même chose et ce
en commençant et ça recommencera est-ce
que ce que j'ai appris une épaisseur
c'est que ça lui prendrait résultats ça
c'est la première marche
c'est à dire que ce qu'on a cru à mon
avis ce que j'ai cru en tant
qu'économiste y est ils sortent d'autres
mots bien souvent convient en abc ce que
j'ai cru qu'on va leur donner c'était le
ruissellement c'était bien que la
croissance qui est belle
sérieusement c'est faux c'est la
polarisation qui domine les plus beaux
dans tous les domaines la personne des
sociétés et lille devienne plus pauvres
les polices de présenter quand en fait
je me souviens de l'étrangler avec un
pénis de l'époque se paie car la famille
et j'avais dit la politique celle
inverse d'apposer sa signature sur l'air
du temps c'est compte amender et
comptant des fils mais on s'en fout et
avoir abandonné cette volonté s'appelle
aménagement des territoires
on en voit exactement exactement des
conséquences honneur 1re point c'est ça
c'est une volonté est monté absolument
nous chante et aller loin dans les
affaires se connaissant de ces questions
les gens travaillent dessus de lui
depuis longtemps ça doit aller loin et
poser des questions gênantes
parce que ça laisse pondi hegedus a
beaucoup maintenant énormément prendre
du temps d'hésitation d'un certain comme
un génie de combat
pour cette première robin la deuxième
remarque l'objet hier toute innovation
la première c'est que mon métier c'est
long depuis très longtemps
vous savez que ses idées sur leur art
est absolument clé imaginez quand vous
retrouvez vos questions le livre dans le
bureau du maire de toulouse d'un iphone
5 si le préfet de région qu'il y ait ce
que je peux voir genevois est interdit
d'y jeter dans la garonne correspond
elle conclu
et quand je vois que la réponse à ça
c'est de réintégrer la gestion dont un
merci je meurs
ces agences de bassins comme si ce
modèle qui était célébrée partout en
finale monde entier avait justement des
gestion démocratique avait des conflits
usages qui vont se développer est de
plus en plus tendue vous avez lu il ya
86 actuellement qui sont en alerte et
briques alimentaires et donc ça combien
vous premièrement c'est différent si
cette différenciation de fait
de fait cet écartement des de france
alors pour aller dans les palais de ben
ali ils sont que je participe activement
à une action qui a commencé un peu
d'arguments mais qui se développe si
elles sont fermées parce qu'il ya
il ya tout et descentes de modulation
modulation à 300 surveillants aussi sur
pétition de la troisième tendance
c'est ce formidable gâchis de noter il
ya des initiatives partout et ce que
j'ai vu moi dans la cour d'une fois le
10e rang à rochefort c'était ça des
initiatives et se diriger dans cet
exemple je devais que notre elles n'ont
rien à voir si c'est un pitre en pole
hausse occupe de livres 6 et dans
d'autres régions
c'est des centres sociaux c'est les
seuls endroits allumé au coeur c'est le
seul service militaire où toutes les
générations peuvent se retrouver
donc pourquoi est ce que on ne connaît
pas ce qui se passe ailleurs dans les
rangs
c'est le premier article de la
différenciation d'autres actions ce
point le plus bas et donc mais pour
quelle raison on aurait eu droit de les
expérimenter longtemps et avec le choix
de chacun hélas ce qui le fera mais je
fuirai là dessus c'est que c'est
incroyable et ça sert si français le
schapi deux semaines et à mesure de
gêner
bonjour et aux jambes c'est cette cette
contradiction
en dix ans on se méfie de
l'expérimentation mais refuse évasion
et moi je dirai rien là-dessus l'égalité
elle est pas dans les fêtes
l'inégalité grandit donc plus
d'expérimentations plus délagation plus
de la liberté plus d' écoute de ce qui
se fait à l'échelle des territoires et
j'entends ceux qui perdent est très
chaude et bien des questions physiques
c'est la question d'échelle à quelle
échelle je finirai là dessus une
excursion
pardon c'est un pardon désolé c'était
l'un des spots c'est bien le non c'est
bien qu'un certain rené breton est
arrivé à son terme
les bacs intensifs comment est ce qu'on
articulé transition comment est-ce qu'on
articulé transition et donc oui religion
est ce que c'est la commune puisque
c'est les agglomérations et vesely est
ce que c'est une région encore faut-il
qu'ils aient des raisons tient sans ce
jeu graphique et je m'appelais et
historique d'un viol donc ces questions
sont posées
ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est pour
ça que franchement moi je suis
absolument passionné par votre avis à
ceux c'est pas du tout ma nature d'être
grandiloquent mais nous sommes ici avec
en question la république je vous prenez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors la république la nullité sont
rasés comment elle fonctionne comme on
ne peut mieux fonctionner comment la
différenciation peut la faire mieux
fonctionner moi bien d'ailleurs mais
peut-être là encore il faut savoir où on
est et où vas-tu l'ip laurent maire de
sceaux et secrétaire général de
l'association des maires de france
merci jean d'abord je veux remercier le
groupe centriste du sénat d'avoir
organisé cette rencontre et d'avoir
conduit mesure est juste de rappeler
quelques points qui paraissent
importants qui n'ont pas été encore
encore été évoquée la première chose
c'est que ce mot décentralisation chaque
année à peu prestigieux pas
d'aujourd'hui ça fait très longtemps que
tu as this man une cinquantaine d'années
rappelle que la loi dit de faire elle
s'appelait pas de les emprunter s'il
s'appelait droits et libertés et des
collectivités territoriales et que le
projet de loi qui a été fait sous la
précédente majorité par le poser des
quatre saclay
réponse pour les responsabilités des
collectivités territoriales à remplacer
leurs responsabilités par liberté
c'était normal parce qu'avant c'était
l'ombre
mais comme aux non c'était pas le mot
décentralisation est arrivé après même
s'il avait utilisé toute l'histoire
générale ont d'ailleurs toujours par
opposition à ce temps l'opposition
devient majorité en général france
elle oublie la décentralisation ça s'est
passé sous préfet nationale
la deuxième chose que je rappeler ces
deux ya des dispositions dans la loi de
faire des positions très importantes en
matière de gestion en matière de
délégation des compétences de l'état et
en matière de gestion de ses délégations
oui le transfert de l'exécutif du préfet
au président département région la
question de la génétique sionisation le
des actes et non plus avant on était a
priori l'organisation la fonction
territoriale jean moulin dès qu'on est
sérieux tout ça sont des mesures
présentant un caractère politique pour
sa part mais aussi de gestion pour
d'autres et des principes sont toutefois
restés et parmi ces principes il ya
d'abord le principe de montupet du
collectif sur une autre et ce principe
là en réalité il rend rigidifie de
paiement l'organisation institutionnelle
actuelle une deuxième scène un deuxième
élément aussi qu'il n'a pas été
orientées client
d'ailleurs ce que jamais d'évoquer cette
remise en question c'est le fait que
contrairement à ce qui se passe dans la
plupart des pays
le maire en france est aussi
représentant des états ce qui crée un
lien tout à fait particulier dans le
pays culturellement historiquement entre
le vert et l'état les départements et
les régions ne sont pas de ce coup là et
donc c'est par l'espèce d'addition de
poupées russes que nous avons on à la
commune le maire avec une relation
directe avec l'état et puis on a
d'autres systèmes dès qu'ils n'ont pas
c'est d'ailleurs la preuve on dit c'est
que faire
la réforme récente on a finalement
supprimé la clause de compétence
générale des départements et des régions
je vous rappelle ça vaut pas tout à fait
d'accord ou pas simplement qu'on va
appeler ses fondamentaux naquit à mon
sens donc empêche une évolution
extrêmement important l'institutionnel
surpris en tournée tout à l'heure on va
pas ce qu'est prononcée le mode
fédéraliste et venir dans des milieux
parce que shazam ici mon patelin
généralistes c'est pas une révolution
c'est pas une réforme de la constitution
c'est une révolution totale
ça veut dire que le cinéma chinois ça
veut dire que le partage des ressources
fiscales
les pubs ça veut dire mais je dirais que
la justice administrative n'existe plus
la loi n'est pas le même enfin bref
c'est une
c'est une révolution totale on peut pas
parler de fédéralistes sans voir
l'ambiance de l'architecturé
institutionnelle ni d'ailleurs mon sens
de la lecture des fiances publiques
donc je pense qu'ils moi je trouve que
c'est sympa parce que ça fait on s'amuse
mais ça n'est pas très clair maintenez
on ne voit pas je pense pas que je pense
pas qu est gaza
donc pour tout dire un rapport à ce
qu'elle consomme entre julien de appelé
je crois que on a bien vu aussi tiens
parce que la chambre constitutionnelle
j'arrive valeur m'a parlé la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2003 a tout de même
été
échec enfin un événement est révolté r
je pense de laporte ministre évoque été
offert afin seulement c'était tellement
de phagocyter par l'administration dans
l'histoire on y est non poivet arrivée
de réformes qui dit d'ailleurs non pas
que la république est décentralisée sont
celles a résumé dans l'organisation et
les centres existent qui n'est pas du
tout la même chose n'est pas du tout
dans l'organisation on les a menés dans
le fonctionnement des choses n'est pas
tout la plaie de kinois et qu'on a
également eu cette réforme
constitutionnelle cette histoire
extraordinaire qui a valu d'ailleurs un
départ homérique au sénat du bond dont
daniel hoeffel été dégradés portant sur
les questions de la part déterminante
des ressources trois points et c'est la
loi des mécaniques
c'est l'avis d'emmanuel 2004 qui a été
malheureusement voté par erreur des
époques en fait a défini des ressources
du rapport du tout commence par saluer
dolled up constitutionnel qui était fait
à cette époque là et qui a abouti à la
justification de la privation des
libertés systonic façon progressive avec
la paix fiscale donc justification a
causé constitutionnel comme du poum
on est enfin prête donc l'adjoint
positionne le veut nous ne la mènera pas
forcément grand chose et verizon un
dévot natif de la bernina remo on aura
du souci
et je m'applique cette affaire des
maires et des relations militaires pour
bien le dire que c'est pas claqué son
deuil du nombre de communes ne pas se
régler par natacha elle va se régler
demain sur un chemin très difficile et
qui a commencé à écrire le sénat il ya
beaucoup travaillé et j'espère c'est la
commune noël ce que les communes ne
s'est pas une autre appli tata paulette
et la communauté est une commune et donc
le maire comme une lettre c'est lui qui
devient représentant de l'état sur le
terrain cette communauté c'est pas
pareil c'est pas présent interpol qui a
des rôles un peu particulier donc la
seule façon pour non pas régler un
problème parce que moi je ne vous at il
pas un problème mais pour ni organiser
les choses peuvent être de manière peu
d'atomes mieux répondre aux besoins
armes c'est évidemment d'aller vers la
paix nouvelle époque
nous souhaitons un business c'était
vraiment un principe fort que ce soit
mon père évidemment ça prend du temps
cela prend du temps et je pense le
chemin dans notre pays tel qu'il est
avec sa culture et l'histoire qui et
quel chemin
quel chemin le chemin viable heures d'un
car tout ça qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
bah on peut continuer en fait ce on a
déjà commencé même s'il est parfois nous
parlons pas trop
c'est à dire à prendre des 100 avoir de
grands débats fils d'odin parce que ça
sert à rien mais simplement en prenant
loi après loi avec des oies
bavard car entre nous soit dit
d'ailleurs comment alors stéphane parler
du cnn pour dépecer lunettes
on voit parfois on nous présente des
fesses nues quand même ça va trop loin
dans le détail il faut laisser comme un
peu d'enjeu manière vous dis ah bah oui
messieurs dames sophie desaulle et quand
je dis aux bureaux
c'est la loi des comme ça et quand on
demande des lignes valable c'est la loi
c'est des projets de loi et des
amendements et dans le dit la bible
comme ce sont des amendements et même
parfois très seule
la seule solution c'est en effet
politiques publiques par politiques
oublient trop vite quand on voit qu'elle
ouvre slater sauf d'état l'humain
comtois question fut démarche du
grenelle qui devait traîner tout un peu
aux différentes collectivités dans leurs
compétences
sans revenir ce principe de l'hôpital
national puisque ça pas prier cette
chaire est évidemment immédiatement
espèce de révolution sur les arguments
pas le pas le gérer c'est à dire parfois
des fautes qui sont exprimées quant tout
à l'heure s'évade par les deux
délégations des villes et des cultures
car pourquoi ça n'a pas très bien marché
en bretagne et pourquoi ça ne marche pas
ailleurs parce que simplement les villes
pour les départements de la région mange
la drac et du tout la région impose sa
volonté
ces financements propos nuancés et donc
les autres viennent sur ce principe de
cette demande tel c'est pour ça ça n'est
pas seulement la haute administration
aussi les autres donc voyez ces
solutions dans ce concert n'était plus
de marge de manoeuvre au cas par cas
allez la contractualisation sa
contracture et il faut le faire ça
demande un effort de monde mais ça se
fait mal donc ça se fait et et vous
disiez adaptation aussi une évaluation
naturellement sa nouvelle relation ces
collectivités elles-mêmes avec le partir
de ce qu'elles seront discutées entre
elles et conclure je dirais que je
reprendrai ma vie tu as dit les mères
sont essentiels à notre démocratie
oui c'est vrai mais pas seulement les
maires quel qu'il soit avec 2000 santé
son siège son support du pays
elle évoquera ses seniors dames et
sacrés français le soin du pays
ils sont essentiels au fonctionnement
d'hara kiri forcée d'un seul
commençaient à présent plus suffisamment
les jantes est essentielle si vous
d'essentiel aussi tout simplement à la
vie quotidienne de nos concitoyens parce
que même si l'on parle eux mêmes les
moyens du père ils sont en tout cas à
vous donner des porte parole auprès des
chais qui peut-être d'intéressement je
pense que j'ai entendu c'est que j'irai
vers d'autres choses dans le passé
enfin avec l'âge et l'expérience en
semaine
au contraire je pense qu'on a beaucoup
plu sera pas de travail en simplement
sans utiliser de grands mots clés sans
faire appel à des grands débats
philosophiques je pense que nous avons
dépassé ce stade et qu'il faut donc
simplement de travailler sur le terrain
ensemble compte actualiser de la marge
de manoeuvre demande au législateur de
ne peut être interdit par la loi
c'est dans ce domaine m voilà c'est ce
genre de jeu nous n'allons pas non plus
loire mais notre vison justement
contractualisation alors jean louis
valentin vous êtes président d'une
communauté d'agglomération qui est celle
du cotentin où l'ajustement département
il ya des grands à dire qu il ya aussi
les communes nouvelles
comment vous vous avancez cette question
de différentiel et république
décentralisée est ce qu'il faut le lire
à le dire crûment de fer avec quels mots
merci j -pd et ravitaille beaucoup
d'intérêt j'ai trouvé que sur le plan
juridique et sous l'autorité l'effet
dépasse néanmoins si je le comprends ton
expérience de praticiens et des le joker
j'ai trouvé qu'il était un petit peu
éloigné de la réalité actuelle du niveau
et de la réalité
je montre aujourd'hui d'aspiration
principal
quelquefois c'est une aspiration la
stabilité ça fait maintenant 12 ans que
je suis et ça fait 12 ans que je vis
dans une instabilité politique
absolument je le dis j'ai été prise d'un
nouveau type polo des promus avec
intérêts des présidents qui avait
fusionné avec notre dynamique
et puis j'ai participé et contribué à la
création
[Musique]
130 mais quelle que soit la taille sais
pas quelles que soient les
caractéristiques différentes que c'est
ensemble puissent avoir le nom pour
peut-être confrontés sur tous les sujets
à une véritable instabilité joly qui
devient ainsi que c'est l'insécurité est
un problème non seulement pour le thé
mais aussi pour les fonctionnaires
territoriaux qui sont chargés des pieds
pour essayer d'en atténuer les effets et
surtout pour l'esprit car il faudra
qu'on n'oublie pas ce débat que la
finalité de l'ensemble des émissions est
d'être au service à la fin de leur
territoire et les citoyens au delà de
savoir quelle est la formule juridique
et le cadre institutionnel pertinents
qu'ils soient plus ou moins jacobins
d'où un g1 l'action
les sensibilités une appréciation du
passé différentes viennent probablement
pas celle d'une partie de l'assistance
la deuxième chose dont nous avons besoin
les jours ça va avec la première dame
ont besoin de visibilité dans l'exercice
des compétences observé j'ai commencé ma
vie publique bien avant d'être élu en
1990 et à l'époque je me souviens qu'on
parlait déjà au parlement et ailleurs de
la clarification des compétences et de
la clarification de l'intervention des
flagships dit qu il y avait déjà une
polémique sur les financements croisés
et il y avait déjà eu des cas par la
commune qui devait avoir plus de
compétence générale aux fonds qui serait
bon ton est assez progressistes deux
très récemment caractérisé intervention
départements des régions car à l'époque
des faits c'est encore embryonnaire et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est en train
de perdre de vue la nécessité de
continuer et on me semble que ce travail
est tout à fait fondamental pour d'abord
permettre la compréhension à la croix
par le citoyen et par l'élu municipal de
lac champlain et ensuite pour avoir un
bon élan et un bon équilibre entre
l'efficacité de la dépense qui doivent
également perdu et la proximité a décidé
et je trouve que depuis 15 ans en
la loi c'est simple on avait plutôt que
des programmes ans
c'est bien que ce que je vais dire va
être présent très critiqué par les
partis de l'assistance je trouve que
depuis le début des années 2000
car depuis les lois fois les chevènement
jusqu'à l'époque où jusqu'à aujourd'hui
on a plutôt eu en matière d'organisation
territoriale et des collectivités
locales
un état qui a été assez stratège assez
volontariste d'être parfois trop
enfin je plains tellement choquant
qu'ils ne soient pas comme lorsqu'il a
bien des domaines où il applique sa tête
capacité d'anticipation une certaine
vision des points mais reconnaître
secret est je pense qu'on a globalement
progressé même si il ya eu des choses
qui n'ont pas été à leur terme même s'il
ya eu probablement des années noires et
un certain nombre de pratiques parfois
les autorités donc ce travail de
lisibilité d'accord je vais parler
beaucoup plus important de vie de
permettre d'avoir des droits locale
différente si ce débat sur cette
question des droits locaux et de
l'adaptation du droit en outre à des
mesures jouent alors je ne sens pas
d'appétence par les élus de mon
appartement pour la production d'ananas
je sens de l'appétence pour une
interprétation flexible de jeu sont
d'appétence pour une utilisation
l'inflation 1 pas cheap mais je ne sens
pas de volonté de produire nous mêmes
droits peut-être sommes-nous d'ailleurs
un département assez légitimiste
habitués salut sonia de la provôté et
vers le faire sont pas moins des
normands peut-être sur une herse
élitiste et tocqueville
peut-être sommes-nous si à ces mots tv
dans la manière dont nous regardons les
choses en tout cas voilà il n'ya pas
nous de d'appétence pour une
différenciation marquer en revanche il
ya bien sûr une volonté de pouvoir agir
de manière souple et flexible adaptable
et je partage ce cas là je vais le
sillage de la loi
souvent tu perds mais bien plus de
choses que des régimes dérogatoires
extrêmement contraignant nous d'ailleurs
pour donner un exemple nous avons
utilisé la loi d'août
kaba création d'un conte d'agglomération
pour rendre des compétences
nancy susvisé matin et nous sommes
appuyés sur la petite du coach hervé
collectif était bien en faisant les
services communs c'est à dire nous avons
permis à l'ensemble des communes qui
souhaitaient de pouvoir continuer à
gérer des compétences sur un bassin de
vie à l'échelle de la coke et puis je
vois juste terminer en disant que nous
avons enfin sa part importante des
besoins de correction
la différenciation d'adaptation oui mais
n'oublions pas que nous avons quand même
à mener des politiques publiques qui
doivent avoir sur le téléphone satellite
et france à l'urbanisme si vous laisser
trop de pouvoirs locaux sur le sujet
urbanisme j'allais probablement aboutir
à la consommation excessive d'alcool
vous allez à petit hadj résidentiel qui
va habiter un certain nombre espaces
périphériques et vous allez sur le lien
dépêchant par ailleurs les données sur
la loi littoral à venir un relâchement
considérable de la pression en faisant
attention nous avons nous sommes dans
l'action publique et cette fois grâce à
mon sens c'est un mix entre la
centralité vient de cinq centrales et je
trouve que dans le communalisme actuelle
je ne me retrouve pas parce que tu
pousses qui bien ta commune est bon et
que tout ce qui vient intercommunalités
ou une structure qui est une structure
déboires et jeux comme étant source de
carcans supportable je crois qu'il faut
redonner à cette notion d'aménagement du
territoire et de cohérence et d'unité
des politiques une certaine heure à
condition bien sûr qu'on arrive à
grappiller ça va rendre difficile avec
une proximité dans la gestion d'un
certain nombre de compétences et ceci me
semble t'il peut-être fait aussi bien
dans l'érection dans les départements
devant les interconnecter les grandes
pluies sans forcément quelques semaines
et bien on pourrait continuer longtemps
mais personnellement je pense que nous
sommes plus aujourd'hui sur un temps
d'adaptation et de digestion
merci
[Musique]
desagneaux a acquis pour une ministre on
est sur cette table ronde où on parle
différenciation et république
décentralisée avec les mots pour le dire
comment tant pis pleurant de marge de
manoeuvre de contractualisation pour
avancer vers cette adaptation
jean louis valentin lui dis attention on
a besoin aujourd'hui de stabilité
juridique de visibilité dans les
politiques territoriales
mais il traduit flexibilité les
souplesses jean marie bockel
quels sont vos grands quels sont les
mots du président de la délégation
sénatoriale aux collectivités
territoriales et à la décentralisation
défense nation et république
décentralisée
comment évoluer comment aussi répondre
ce qu'on a évoqué depuis le début la
nécessité d'avoir de meilleures
évaluations si les politiques publiques
par contre c'est pas comment dépasser
des questions de fond si on ne va pas à
l'échangé lamentable aime le rappeler
les effets de ces politiques pour nos
concitoyens
au fur et à mesure mais si jean-luc en
mesure de l'avancée de ferreira
passionnant
on est amené je suis amené à remettre en
question les quelques certitudes qui me
restait les nageurs je veux dire par là
que
lorsque j'ai la suite des jacqueline
gourault à la présidente de cette
délégation il ya quelques années avec un
grand plaisir sous se retrouver au sein
d'une délégation qui est
sociologiquement précéda taurian cap
avec une majorité de collègues qui
chantent plutôt de petite commune du
monde rural et où la sensibilité grandes
villes agglomérations et c était
extrêmement minoritaire et qui trouve
que c'était la mienne de sensibilité est
déjà arrivé là avec mon expérience des
certitudes
mon regard sur la relation comme une
communauté et franchement à mon âge
avait déjà un peu la pénibilité mais
lâché du approfondie en quelque sorte
mais je dis ça pas simplement pour
patrick houle
on a tous découle pas abattre et d'effia
été exprimés et parce que je pense que
on est vraiment je reviendrai dans un
instant sur du mondial là qu'on veut
aller
mais dans sept d'entre deux où il ya des
tas de trucs qui fonctionna pas où il ya
ce qu'a dit eric orsenna et on sait on
voit mais ya pas que ça pendant les
travaux les ventes continuent la clis le
viol neuf c'est à dire que et une france
qui est à changer il ya déjà la france
qui vient où il ya des jeunes par
exemple
oui il ya des attaques humilité
1 ce qui fonctionne le travail nous à la
délégation on nous toujours essayé
d'être très concret regrettable c'est
sur ces dix tables thématiques on avait
par exemple 120 communautés un travail
essentiellement axée sur les bonnes
pratiques et des bonnes pratiques
elles nourrissent en grande partie sur
cette mention le texte qui va venir à
partir du 8 octobre au sénat
et c'est vrai que il y a quand même
beaucoup d'intercommunalité qui
fonctionne pas si mal il y en a d'autres
qui trouvent que ça pourrait aller
beaucoup mieux mais qu' il faut pas de
nouveau changer la loi il faut pas de
nouveau déstabiliser ce qui essaye quand
même de se construire et puis les
endroits où effectivement on a le
sentiment que cette commune nouvelle
émergentes et une réponse une réponse
aux rebelles c'est par la réponse c'est
une réponse à en 2012 on vient ceux qui
trouvent que beaucoup j'ai la
caractéristique d'avoir un téléphone
décentralisation la cua 37 ou 38 ans que
le jeune député donc c'est une époque je
dois de faire je me souviens avec
l'enthousiasmé
je vais bien regarder un petit peu les
principes très vite on n'est pas sur le
passé mais c'est toujours bienvenu bien
et simplement le discours de faire à
l'assemblée nationale libérez la digicel
étouffant les citoyens à l'entreprise
les cellules faire davantage confiance
sur le cac le terrain à la proximité
faire émerger une bonne citoyenneté
ne pas fragiliser l'état mais leur
enfoncer en l'allégeant de vote m
l'addition de l'étape
c'est formidable au fond c'était déjà le
thème employées à l'époque le principe
de subsidiarité
ensuite les années ont passé comme je
dis l'instant tout n'a pas été négatif
il est quand même eu grâce à la
centralisation des territoires qu'on
prenne davantage de responsabilités
quand pris des initiatives qui ont été
dans l'expérimentation
je regarde le monsieur roger parce que
c'est vrai que on a tous vécu des
expérimentations formidable il ya
beaucoup de bretons il ya aussi quelques
alsaciens je le suis souviens qu'à
l'époque me brigitte l'a4 adrien zeller
président et l'alsace l'état peut-être
parce que nous étions des modérés
peut-être parce que nous étions
respectueux mais nous a délégué à
déléguer à la région tous les fonds
européens et du coup le président de la
région avait constitué de 7,2 g 7 à une
organisation avec les représentants des
différents types de commercialité pour
voir ça ensemble en amont puis levé
dossier avec l'état local ça n'a jamais
fait de demande si ça n'a pas fait en
bout et qu'on trompe est mais c'était
fort bien réussie pour dire la même
chose sur la la réforme de la sncf ou
d'ailleurs soit dit en passant
certains investissements qui dans bien
des territoires ont jamais été fait sur
les réseaux locaux sont encore se
dégrader les ponts les rails etc
je dis pas qu'on n'est parfait mais
grâce à ça et sans tambour ni trompette
grâce à l'expérimentation
on a pris la main sauf que en france
jusqu'à aujourd'hui l'expérimentation
c'est un premier pas vers la
généralisation et alors je suis pas en
train de dire que c'est automatique
parce que si on sait être relativement
discret et ne pas trop se signaler on
peut être très longtemps dans une
expérimentation qui l'a 8 amour données
s'installe entre
quand même là il ya quand même peut-être
un changement et venant du passé encore
un mot sur la période qu'on a vécu tel
que je le vois pas ce que la promesse
d'efficacité a été tenue plus ou moins
on avait parlé de beaucoup points de
notre fonctionnement
on appelle à les oublier les trois
spécificités françaises même à l'époque
la décentralisation conçu de façon
centralisée décidé de façon centralisée
et mise en oeuvre avec peu de moyens
donc on n'est pas encore né à télérama
qui sillone voisin l'étape des autres et
je pense qu'il faut pas se fixer cet
objectif nous quand on a travaillé sur
la tombe de sujets la question du statut
de l'élu local ou dans certains pays
c'est comme un formidable
évidemment il ya moins de communes tout
ça c'est une autre donc on part de la
france telle qu'elle est avec sa forge
le galsi bénévolat ça tangue de mer et
on part cette réalité pour voir comment
on peut améliorer le dispositif et puis
il ya aussi lu certains ont dit mais je
veux dire fortement dans cette mise en
oeuvre la centralisation la
fragilisation de l'état local et puise
alors heureusement là aussi pour pas
généraliser il ya autant de situations
un peu de départements ou de régions
nous quand même alors que ce qu'on veut
avec cette différenciation
décentralisation déconcentration
différenciation madame la ministre je
pense que il faut d'abord s'entendre sur
les mots et sans encore une fois espérer
qu'un texte réglera tous mes
la différenciation organisationnel on
veut mieux s'organiser des compétences
sélection d'alsace alcoologie voir la
question des normes ou là on n'est plus
en effet dans la simplicité
quand la simplification en aussi
beaucoup travaillé là dessus avec des
propositions concrètes que dans la
production de l'homme par exemple si
vernon a nommé sous préfet
expérimentateurs sur la saturation des
dogmes tout d'abord auditionné deux à
l'avant délai le haut rhin c'était très
intéressant
ils ont dit à la face qu'ils ont pu
faire ce qu'ils auraient aimé pouvoir
faire les problèmes que ça pose mais on
sent qu'il ya là des pistes et donc pour
pour moi cette démarche delà de la
différenciation
je pense que elle ne peut également en
gardant la la ministre elle ne peut nous
apporter une amélioration que si elle
est comme en direct à partir de quelques
principes extrêmement pragmatique presse
que je dirais modeste
d'une certaine manière parce que comme
disaient les profs de droit tout à
l'heure mon défi mieux c est
il faut qu'on arrive de manière
itérative
avec des allers-retours permanents avec
des critiques de l'évaluation à bâtir un
dispositif dans un cadre faut-il qu'ils
soient constitutionnelles jusqu'à quel
point le mois il y aura le mieux c'est
mais je pense que avec la dimension
financière également un spécialiste de
ces questions
on en a parlé c'est pas le sujet du jour
on peut arriver à apparaître à bâtir
pardon quelque chose et je pense pas
qu'on va défaire la france je pense pas
que ce qu'il ya de positif dans le sens
de l'état une égalité à sa troupe de
principe pense que au contraire réussir
cette démarche à partir des territoires
c'est évidemment conforté l'état moderne
tels que nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
d'un état en matière de solidarité en
matière de quelques règles communes
mais je pense que le le le une certaine
forme d'état la française est arrivée de
l'exercice pense d'ailleurs que madame
la ministre que le pouvoir actuel salma
hayek extrêmement expérimenté d'autres
qui arrivent et stabilité dans d'autres
vies il ya eu dans un premier temps ce
un peu ce défaut ce travers français
avec aussi parfois goodell a si les
territoires année vraiment considérer
les enjeux et passez pas gaspiller pas
l'argent public parfois des
investissements discutable et c'est ce
qui est vraiment l'arbre cache la forêt
ça irait mieux et je pense que des
aspects positifs de cette période
gilet jaune quelques au cdh a rappelé
c'était quand même je parlais tout à
l'heure de deux modes savoir de remettre
en question pensent que l'on soit
content de responsables de l'état en
tout ap
j'écris que cette espérance je crois que
c'est le cas se remettent aussi en
question par rapport à la place de
l'état face aux fruits et ce pont datant
des territoires ne décourage pas les
maires
c'est une richesse formidable que même
bien compris que mon est en train de
changer
que eux-mêmes devait accepter des
solidarités nouvelles mais avons à
tisser à maillé cette plaine france en
en gardant sa richesse son dynamisme
car celle là aussi elle est unique en
europe ne lâche pas la fois pour l'ombre
[Applaudissements]
merci jean marie bockel alors vos
réactions vos questions c'est d'abord
peut-être première question à philippe
le mans parce que et vocaux et au maire
de soues d'ailleurs sur la
différenciation par rapport à votre
commune
on a entendu les bretons les alsaciens
mais le début franciliens ont le rapport
à la question de l'arrêt ce plat de la
différenciation comment il aborde bon va
quitter on va faire nos colloques la
question la question d'organisation de
la vie folle parisienne non mais j'ai
alors que la crise 1 il faut dès lors et
non pas qu'ils se lever la patte m'a
approché d'un micro peut-être eh bien on
va faire circuler la parole
bonjour a relevé divers malaises frais
non je ne suis pas une élue bretonne
mélanie et l'érable et maire du tampon
et jean prouvé qu'on vous remercier de
m'avoir invité ce colloque est
passionnant de choses en question il ya
plus trop qui arrive il est beaucoup
question d'un colloque d'égalité
syndiqués de liberté du droit
différenciation n'est pas beaucoup de
fraternité et je voulais savoir pour
vous ce droit la différenciation en quoi
ça peut permettre de mieux prendre en
compte les difficultés de nos
concitoyens particulièrement lumineuse
mais question c'est que l'organisation
si elle doit changer c'est vraiment
faire quelque chose donc quoi et c'est
vrai que sa question m internet et 21
corps coeur et deux seulement quand même
dire que en termes de fluidité
parfois les fonctionnaires ou conseils
départementaux et un objet à ceux des
ars et si je mens l'attendre la
colocation de bombay et plupart des
pauvres ont inventé qui est celle
aujourd'hui par tous pour obtenir un
conseil départemental maintiennent n'a
pas un tour maximum et les gardes même
point les gens sont en butte à ce qui
était la condition en dessinant
aujourd'hui que ce type d'échangés de la
structure des personnes âgées est
construite avec les personnes donc voilà
je pense aussi du côté des collectivités
locales attention à ce qu'il a confiance
avec les acteurs notamment donné la
parole à eric orsenna parce que donc
plus des décharges qui a été passée eric
avant le nôtre comme il y avait
justement cette articulation entre
liberté égalité et les conditions de
patates et tout à fait raison puis les
deux rames
c'est le propre camp la deuxième phrase
si le pendant négatif du positif du
boramar si finir chez le psy pas pour ce
que j'ai entendu partout en france sur
la lecture publique comme sur la musique
comme science et non comme sur la
capacité de monter dans le soi disant à
son entretien le sait si la vente est
donc l'heure ce qui se passe dans les
municipalités salué notamment
c'est mon travail principal
surveillerait c'est de réduire le sénat
c'est à dire qu elle est
on se faisant attaquer par les cultures
professionnelles qui disent vous en
foutez lui là on va le conduire et
simplement il ya eu 4 sociale je les ai
c'est un bon français d'en digérer à ce
questionnaire est que prône entre avec
les jolis chronique on ans par
l'apprentissage dans les franges l on en
cours par le soutien aux immigrés et
petit à petit aux interligues
et moi j'ai vu quelque chose qui m'a
énormément travaillé à la vie à gogo
c'est que les gens qui venaient parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de l'universitaire
par exemple ou pour toute autre raison
ou parce qu'ils avaient chaud on leur
donnait quoi premier musée nan parce que
mes gars t'es con en plus facilement
dans un musée j'avais 10 ans et noah
musique on sait le rôle
à ces mots clés de temps c'est mieux de
chaleur ce que j'appelle de chaleur de
réduire ses parts insupportable qui sont
le scénario
merci la capacité aussi donc à
expérimenter avec un partenaire avec la
société civile avec les habitants et les
associations reçues un shampoing paraît
bien fade en simple citoyen
qu'un paradis village et le quotidien je
ne sais pas et je m'étonne que nous
français qui aura si nous impose son jeu
terminant leur bébé beaucoup de bras les
réglementations sont des transpositions
la vie sociale aurait pu être étendue
plus largement on parlera d'autant plus
le
et à paris ont tout simplement un jeu
vidéo ce débat je vais évoquer le cas
récent de cet arrêté qui ont été signés
par certains maires de terrebonne la
diffusion de produits potentiellement
dangereux et qu'il n'était repris par le
gouvernement bien que pressé et
d'ailleurs les roseaux et conservé deux
mondial en 4e position
on peut encore reprendre d'autres
interventions parce que je voyais
beaucoup d'intuition et d'ailleurs
vraiment dire que une agression descente
nous nous apprêtons g4 mairie gillois
cher je suis ici
au département à un département
dynamique au mondial
ce que je voulais dire c'est que la
notion d'expérimentation la notion de
différenciation les deux points de vue
sont assises sur la notion fatalité ces
points soit 0 des territoires venons
prendre en compte les besoins les
habitants qui vont s'engager pour un
risque a également besoin jusqu'à mener
la différenciation je pense que ces deux
notions sont importantes à privilégier
dans les législations qui sont à
élaborer
parce que je sois j'ai dû conserver au
cimetière des différentes interventions
c'est que la houle expérimente une seule
la différenciation c'est aussi des en
conservant un chien c'est à dire que
vous ne trouverez ces expériences a
provoqué des dysfonctionnements mais
qu'elle pourra effectivement je pense
que c'est important qu'ils ont des
collectivités avec jean ou un peu
pouvoir faire évoluer le droit et le
droit constitutionnel
merci monsieur oui qu'on soit tous les
noms de l'état je suis un simple
conseiller municipal 19 ans je vous
considère donc en apprentissage en
politique je suis aux siens je remercie
mes acteurs
voir l'idée japon beaucoup c'est
passionnant et je vais sans doute
beaucoup de bêtises partenaires la boxe
mais sa plainte et répété lieu je suis
inscrit en l'air puisque non seulement
campagne principale ce titre en faisons
nous le faisons beaucoup de pharmaciens
et dans le champ découvre l'autre la loi
en attendant le c'est comme ça que
j'appelle et jurent qu'elles allouent
vers ces contrées
d'après ce que j'ai compris
écoute attentivement un professeur
chabrier nous avons tout l'arsenal
nécessaire pour parvenir là est la
question je me posais en racontant la
finalité c'est quoi ces rois plus de
pouvoir faire mieux et là je rejoins
plein sur senna qui disait tu es
ministre qu'on s'en fout en gros qu'est
ce que tu comptes faire
il a cité aussi le psu et tout de suite
je pense à quelqu'un que j'admirais
beaucoup mais c'est le cas avec cette
fable commissariat et parvenir au
conseil municipal mais parfois ne
parlons pas
la motié la france ça résoudrait le
problème ça fera des ressources
candidats notamment qui suit d'île de
france
je suis effaré pouvoir depuis 30 ans le
sort qui est réservé le territoire
j'entends par là - région et des mots
qui ne tient que je n'ai pas c'est
entendu ses soldats
des régions plus riches et fraternité
il peut sans que beaulieu au lieu de
nous et loire nous avons encaissé trente
dernières années si je peux me permettre
au continent coucher pour personne il me
semble qu'en dehors surtout manqué
d'idées et de cours à
l'indifférenciation que j'ai un peu peur
je crois qu'après le pont avait dit à
l'ap habilité contrat et confiance et
surtout on ne peut rien faire sans
moyens alors tout ceci mais avec quels
moyens
par exemple il faut réindustrialiser la
france des territoires
tchéidé partie quand vous appelez vos
réponses par exemple merci est erroné
demande
oui j'avais
devant des recherches
je suis étonné quand on essaie de
résoudre à notre échec est tout petit
problématiques comme par exemple essayer
d'éliminer des déchets qui sont déposés
au point de nos rues dans des sacs
poubelle et qu'on m'oblige maintenant à
passer par le dépôt d'une plainte auprès
de la gendarmerie
alors que nous avions voté hier à gagner
une disposition comme quoi par décision
du conseil municipal nous mettions 100
euros pour éliminer ces déchets cantons
ont prouvé le contrevenant
eh bien monsieur le préfet m'a écrit
pour me dire je serai plus possible
maintenant il faut que je dépose plainte
auprès de lui de la sanzar horizon que
ça à faire en recevoir des plaintes
comme un soufflet collègues dire
évidemment de la communauté de nouvelles
qu'ils ont été avertis puisque les
déchets relève de la compétence
intercommunale et qu'on passe notre
temps à les déposer des plaintes
pour que certains aboutisse le plus part
du temps un non lieu
c'est toujours le cas alors qu'attendre
et ça c'était bien de garde sont
trouvées hors semaine après les soirées
seront que plus jamais des questions et
j'avais fallait bien ça c'est les choses
comme ça qui ont trois hommes la vie des
mères ils ont la possibilité de rester
au quotidien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a eu l'idée qu'un fossé après avoir
découvert donc leurs différentes mais
tombait la plainte
il plonge sur semois effet plus
généralement puisque on arrive au terme
de notre table euros cette nécessité les
interpellations qui ont été aussi celle
pour plus de simplicité
et puis quand on parle de
différenciation merci la différenciation
de qu'on peut allier à de l'innovation
dans les rapports avec les autres
acteurs du teil fois on a doté la
collectivement mais c'est juste une
réflexion par pascal terrasse relègue le
vendée la volaille dans l'otan qui n'a
pas la chose c'est que comme la
délibération du conseil municipal
agritubel lorsqu'on optique le maire
serait son vers la salubrité publique et
sécurité
bien sûr mais il doit pouvoir le faire
en comptant sur les forces de police et
sécurité nationale
ça veut dire que en réalité c'est aussi
à la gendarmerie de faire le travail et
deux oui mais le problème c'est que si
les forces de sécurité des semaines
ce territoire ce soit la police la
gendarmerie et refuser qu'on dirait rené
en compte aussi ce type d'incivilités
qui sont donc ces unités profit son
titre du quotidien qui ont été
déterminées par arrêté municipal
je vais te le relais aussi vous pouvez
écouter davantage sur sur les chances de
l'état ça c'est un sujet dont on parle
c'est au volant de la rapide mais si la
personne pour les fans du lausanne sport
alors ensuite deuxième deuxième point
par rapport à cette problématique
spécifique des des sacs déposés avait
donc pour lequel on peut trouver des
adresses
il faut pas en fait mais finalement il
faut juste effectuerez une prestation de
services en raison d'une facture d'envoi
une facture simplement presque tout
service attendue de relégation neuf et
ça marche très bien mais c'est encore
tendeur de 1,7 mais rien au hasard
j'aimerais dire
philippe et monsieur exercices pratiques
de différenciation solide en passant
comme elle elle côtoie travail avait
bien qu'il a fait c'est quoi la
différenciation de manière pratique et
et sans forcément besoin d'un texte
c'est la possibilité je parlais tout à
l'heure de l'expérimentation pour les
vrais fait inquiète car assez bien
fonctionner la possibilité pour un
préfet d'adapter les textes qu'il a à sa
disposition tout amer par un dialogue
direct voire à se superposer
si c'est un problème où il a envie
d'être pas tout seul dans la description
dans le delaware rêver et puis on trouve
un terrain d'entente
et ça fonctionne et puis c'est tout et
l'esp on est obligé de vérifier qu'il
faille absolument passer par une plate
parce qu'on est obligé de demander la
thèse qui précisent les textes existants
donc on s'adapte et d'encrés pas énorme
on savait et ça ne fait de tort à
personne ça doit alors que votre dock un
grand brécé principes républicains et ça
m'amène à dire que la différenciation
ça ne fonctionnera que si c'est possible
et ça a des effets de chevet la base
sinon ça ne se voit pas et la croix
c'est possible merci jean marie bockel
lésés
c'était d'initiative et des élus que
vous soulignez jeu pour terminer cette
[Musique]
course comprendre je voulais juste faire
quelques observations sur la production
les détenus d'abord sur la fraternité
ans trop werner vous pas la technicité
croissante de l'action publique locale
près contre parfois oublier la
fraternité oublier les principaux ou en
tout cas les subordonnées avec
l'occupation qui va être occupé chez soi
procédurales soient développées passion
d'efficacité d'adhérence
comme on est ultra sollicité je le peins
des subventions il peut arriver que
parfois je tel ou tel sujet on en voit
d'autres politiques et que finalement un
certain nombre d'associations supporte
et donc je pense que là dessus il faut
arriver différenciation pas à retrouver
un certain bon sens et essayer parfois
de pouvoir se mettre tous autour de la
table
quelle que soit la collectivité pour
trouver une solution au problème des
larmes sur la solidarité
je pense que la différenciation de rend
beaucoup plus difficile exercice de la
solidarité parce que la solidarité ça tu
que vous avez reçus et lorsque vous êtes
sur des compétences qui va exercer
fortement invoque la région à l'autre
l'exercice pratique de la péréquation de
la redistribution et quand même vous
pouvez difficile donc la différenciation
connais beaucoup de vertus et
certainement pas la vertu de faire une
sorte qu'il soit plus solidaire et plus
en plus mise hors gel
j'ajoute que il ya quand même une
tendance dans la société qui pourra pas
occulter à ce que chacun veut exactement
le voisin nous ce qu'on demande c'est
l'harmonisation des tarifs immédiat bhl
évidemment pas possible même avec la
meilleure volonté joue donc sur
solidarité 10h à 13h30 suis assez
sceptique sur l'europe
ce jeu peut être le premier suicide aqps
aux interventions saverdun que les gens
expriment faisant attention à ce titre
elle commença sur transposition à la
fois des directives européennes
aretha nationale mais aussi parfois par
les administrations locales vis à vis de
delon d'étape ce qui peut aussi arriver
car roger quelques exemples
l'administration régionale
départementale peut parfois dans cette
restriction dans ses recommandations
même que les élus allaient au delà de ce
qui est inventé
on acquiert prescrites par l'état votre
ajouté à ses sketches inédits sur ce
sujet il faut que mambé lui passent eux
aussi attention au niveau local afin de
laisser dominer par la technostructure
administrative a beaucoup de qualités et
qui a aucune expertise et de talent mais
parfois aussi commettre des erreurs
merci jean rède alors tu as on est tenu
par le temps devrait beaucoup bien sûr
pouvoir débattre longtemps sur ces
sujets qui nous passionne collet et
arrive le moment de la synthèse et
perspectives
merci messieurs d'ailleurs je dois
m'excuser également mac et plaques
aurait dû être avec nous mais la vie
ministérielle dans ce département et y
exprime encore j'appelle bêtement
françoise gatel laurent la foule
sénateur du val de marne et la somme aux
belles le professeur de droit social
bercy tellement labadie synthèse et
perspectives a raté de tout ce qui s'est
dit
on va commencer avec vous avec les
parlementaires puissent de notre
colloque était organisé à pau
d'initiative vous en attendiez
certainement des choses ou de ce débat
de ces propositions conclut émerger des
définitions qui ont pu également être
précisé françoise gatel le aujourd'hui
et à ce moment de notre colloque comment
les choses peuvent s'orienter sur la
différenciation cette république dont
l'organisation est décentralisée
comment omar sy solidarité
différenciation ou une commande on peut
le concrètement si avant ses réformes
constitutionnelles ou par à consommer
quels sont aujourd'hui vos propositions
merci encore aux belges en avant de
saluer la mini nous sommes très heureux
de voir laquelle viennent assister à la
fin du second quelques années sur
mansion supprimant des sentry et
l'ensemble des collègues concentrer sur
le travail que nous allons présenter
avant colmar la france et des
propositions qui émanent d'un travail
d'une saison parlementaire conduit par
l'ensemble des communes où sont traitées
la construction d'une personnalité à
ombres d'entrain de notre volonté
c'était le moment le gouvernement
annonce un projet de loi sur la
différence fait changer les 3d notre
volonté c'est de comprendre regardez de
faire mes propositions d'apporter une
pierre
d'une pierre à ce que nous appelons à ce
que nous appelons
parce que contrairement à vivre je
dirais disons le et faisons le ça me
semble important qu'en tout cas cet
après midi j'ai copié but d'aider les
points de vue extrêmement différente
bien que l'exercice était son complexe
parce qu'on tombe différenciation aussi
cette musique qui vient très forte qui
ait fait le souci des qualités j'ai
beaucoup entendu ce qu'a dit eric
orsenna qui dit que dès lors que
l'égalité quand elle vient un peu
frustré contrarier la liberté il n'ya
plus des qualités qu'on voit bien
aujourd'hui que nous sommes dans une
assemblée de ce que j'appelle la
république 2003 est le partenaire vont
mal et que la mini-chaîne annexes
les territoires sont la république des
fraudeurs et malgré pas le niveau
si vous reprenez le constructeur tout ça
et elle se soucie cette volonté de
garantir pour tous c'est l'égalité c'est
à dire l'accès de chacun la liberté à
tous les droits alors laurent cela étant
dit ces propositions et comment
aujourd'hui où c'est la teuf
vous travaillez cette question de
négociation lors cette fiche indique
l'association concrètement on y est venu
en 52 personnes on y ait lieu suite des
événements connus en
bien qu'on se fait fort de coupure qui à
l'époque de france le train de proposer
à france 2 la réunion du complexe que ça
parce que à l'intérieur d'avoir habité
interpol il yad'autres dix pages pour
être élu du val de marne france il seul
territoire la proximité du travail et
est bien desservie par des transports en
commun pas selon que vous êtes dans un
top-10 et la façon de vivre
paul n'est pas du tout la même comme
quoi ils s
et c'est cette diversité et surtout elle
nécessité de trouver les ailes où ce qui
nous amènera ce pour l'instant gelée
elle concept de différenciation concept
qui est maintenant partagée par un
député ont aussi mené une réflexion là
sur ce sujet c'est un projet doit
l'année prochaine même source alors
notre souhait est d'être le plus précis
possible qu'on voit bien à travers
l'intervention de li que les désiste les
idées foisonnent les biens sans
précisions à apporter qui vous paraît
elle qui nous paraissent essentiels
d'abord qu'est ce qu'on appelle
différenciation sur quoi porte qui ferme
ses sources
des compétences en session des
structures la différence pression énorme
c'est aussi qu'est-ce que quelle est
l'ambition on porte dernière cette
notion de différenciation est ce que
c'est une différenciation pour déroger
une différenciation pour adapter à
carreaux
là et quel est le curseur on y est les
ambitions humaines nous on a tendance à
dire d'un centriste la différenciation
c'est d'abord un état d'esprit mais dont
2,7 aussi noté qu'il faut avoir cette
grande et et nous en tant que élus c'est
à nous de nous apporter en premier chef
septe cette volonté cet état d'esprit
alors on a fait une proposition mais
allez dire à deux voix rapidement parce
que finalement elle
elles ont été présentées et par
plusieurs intervenants différents vous
refaire la première opposition à qui des
points un petit peu de ce qui s'y
passait bien d'avancer ces derniers mois
c'est que cette différenciation l2 peut
paraître un droit d'exception c'est à
dire qu'on ne peut pas prévoir une ruse
pacifique
dès lors qu'un territoire des
territoires auront besoin d'adapter le
car a des spécificités locales
on a n'est plus avec beaucoup d'intérêt
les taux d'intérêt et les assassinats
jeanne btan et effectivement il ya un
assez large consensus à l'assemblée
nationale et qui n'avait ça n'a pas été
sonné mais ça n'a pas été sans débat
parce que la justice des élites aux
autres territoires visés seront si
frontalière
dix ans a tant d'autres et une sont
possibles et les régions frontalières
pourquoi aurions nous pas on peut pas
concevoir processus de différenciation
comme une accumulation de lois
d'exception mais il faut à travers un
principe de portée générale fixée le cas
dans lequel s'est différenciation seront
possibles deuxième principe il est sans
doute assez délicat à travers les
interventions d'un seul talent de
l'essonne 7 après 10,6 sur la question
groupe de leur processus de
différenciation et aussi de l'impact que
peut avoir la différenciation sur l'état
lui même lors de l'étape où l'essentiel
c'est à dire parce que les collectivités
aujourd'hui la tension régnant en
revanche à d'état qui fonctionne
différemment
un état qui soit 47 unités nationales
nouvelle je pense la très grande
majorité des français sont très attachés
aux grilles être fait pas mal après ce
processus d'audition 2011 est loin en
revanche par contre ce qu'on souhaite
c'est un état qui soit davantage et
concentré c'est à dire les acteurs
locaux sur le terrain et a coûté 2 avec
le voir en place 2 v représentant départ
qu'il soit en mesure de faire avancer
les projets des collectivités étaient
boudés fait il ya cette question de la
déconcentration
c'est un peu ça promet puisque d'entre
nous au moment de redescendre à
l'irrationnel 40 ans maintenant en
annoncé parallèlement à
ces vidéos seule explication dénoncé une
grosse jusqu'à présent cette fois un des
3 d c'est un des trois des soldes
extrêmement vigilant et compte y passe
ou ça nous paraissait fou les conditions
du succès de la différence est la
troisième opposition
c'est seulement la troisième proposition
part de ce que nous pouvons appeler unis
j'ai perdu 8 2 mg et égales par le
conseil constitutionnel rappelle avec
constance l'importance de l'égalité
et ce principe constitue une dictée on
va dire un obstacle au fait qu' il
combat la possibilité d'accorder à des
collectivités de même catégorie et
compétences le terran mais nous sommes
que cette lecture de légaliser cette
pratique
elle conforte l'objectif et les moyens
et ça a été dit tout à l'heure par
plusieurs intervenants
elle occupe d'un véritable accession de
l'égalité c'est à dire celle des droits
la question c'est comment moment
république vous permettront à chacun
quel que soit le you'll be quelles que
soient ses revenus
quelle que soit sa situation personnelle
d'accéder à l'ensemble des droits et des
fonctions peu plus et donc si la loi
elle est faite comme le disait porta
mise pour les hommes pour les femmes
aussi à la demande et non un fait alors
c'est notre troisième opposition sénat
prises en compte